François Noel buffet le président LR de
la commission des lois est en train de
commencer cette audition Gérald Darmanin
qui est également prêt à prendre la
parole cette audition devrait durer une
heure et demie une heure 45 sans plus
attendre direction la salle Médicis
je rappelle que la séance ne commission
est retransmise en direction sur le site
internet du Sénat
je vous propose car je n'ignore pas
qu'il y aura beaucoup de questions
qu'on essaye de limiter le temps de
questions à deux minutes
ce serait le plus efficace possible
avec Monsieur le Ministre que nous avons
dans le public des élèves de l'école
nationale
de l'École normale supérieure excusez
moi qui sont là et qui participent à nos
travaux ce matin
et j'invite donc les journalistes merci
fermer les portes finalement merci
monsieur le ministre de votre présence
ce matin devant la commission des lois
et d'avoir accepté notre invitation
naturellement celle-ci s'inscrit ensuite
des événements qui se sont déroulés bien
sûr à sainte-solide mais pas seulement
il y a aussi
des mouvements à l'occasion de des
manifestations
contre les retraites
naturellement je fais la distinction
entre ceux qui ont manifesté avec leurs
organisations syndicales dans les
cortèges officiels de ceux qui se sont
mal comportés avec des mal comportés est
encore un terme bien faible
qui ont commis des actes d'agression de
violence
de caractères délictuels voire parfois
on peut se poser la question d'autres
qualifications pénales
en même temps des interrogations qui se
sont fait jour par un certain nombre de
mouvements politiques ou pas ou
associatif
contestant parfois les conditions dans
lesquelles les forces de l'ordre sont
intervenues
et je ne parle pas d'organisation
internationales
type Conseil de l'Europe en tous les cas
pour un de ses représentants une de ses
représentants un de ses représentants
pardon qui ont fait des déclarations
publiques
à l'encontre de nos actions de nos
services de police
sans parler éventuellement
institutionnellement du Défenseur des
droits qui a aussi dit des choses
cet ensemble
de débat parfois même visant à confondre
le rôle de chacun parfois même inverser
les rôles
crée des circonstances qui ne sont pour
nous en tous les cas je pense au sens
large par acceptable nous avons besoin
de clarté
de comprendre exactement les situations
telles qu'elles ont été je rappelle à
tout le monde que moi pour les
événements de Sainte-Souline il y a eu
200 blessés parmi les manifestants dans
deux très graves et 47 parmi les
gendarmes et aussi sans doute que vous
nous préciserez la nature de leur
blessure qui ont été importantes puisque
un certain nombre de témoignages
ou de vos déclarations ont montré que
les forces de l'ordre avaient été aussi
victimes de d'agression d'une immense
violence
l'idée évidemment à la commission des
Lois du Sénat j'imagine que c'était la
même chose précédemment à l'Assemblée
nationale les que vous puissiez exposer
la situation telle que vous l'avez vécu
et dirigée et puis que nous puissions
ouvrir
un jeu de questions et de répondre dans
un climat parfaitement apaisé comme
toujours ici même si parfois il peut
être assez direct mais ce qui est
nécessaire à la vérité du débat voilà
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
merci
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs d'abord je vous
prie de bien vouloir m'excuser pour les
quelques minutes de retard mais comme
vous l'avez dit monsieur le Président
j'étais à la même audition à l'Assemblée
nationale
et évidemment j'ai pu rejoindre au plus
vite possible votre commission auquel je
réponds évidemment à l'invitation
d'abord par par plaisir bien sûr d'être
célèbre pour vous mais aussi évidemment
par devoir puisqu'il est tout à fait
normal bien sûr et ça que les ministres
et notamment misateurs rendent compte de
l'action de ses services et de sa propre
action devant les représentants du
peuple salut évidemment votre public et
ceux qui nous regardent peut-être en
guise d'introduction puisque
effectivement les choses sont un peu
complexes mélangeant à la fois des
exections extrêmement fortes qui ont
lieu au milieu urbain pendant ou à côté
des manifestations pour la réforme
contre la réforme des retraites avec
Sainte Soline qui évidemment ni même
milieu mais rural ni même le même but en
l'occurrence
la racine ni les mêmes actions ont
résumé une semaine de maintien de
l'ordre pour faire très vite comme le
dit la presse ou les attaques politiques
en question et donc je souhaitais vous
présenter ce petit ce petit portfolle
comme on dit à Tourcoing qui résume les
quelques sujets que je voudrais évoquer
devant vous est telle que les choses
sont vues par le ministère de
l'Intérieur je précise par ailleurs que
de nombreuses enquêtes judiciaires sont
ouvertes pour s'insoline comme pour
certaines manifestations non autorisées
ou sauvages à parier dans l'est du pays
et que évidemment je commenterai pas ces
décisions ces actions de justice mais
j'essaierai d'apporter le maximum
d'informations
du ministrateur à sa connaissance
de ces derniers mois je veux vous dire
et je veux constater avec vous mais vous
l'avez parfois souligné compris au Sénat
pour des questions d'actualité qu'il y a
eu de nombreuses manifestations très
importantes en France singulièrement
depuis le début de la réforme des
retraites décidées par le gouvernement
avec parfois plus d'un million de
personnes dans les rues pour plus de 300
actions sans que rien de majeur de ce
soit déroulé en incident
le sujet de la présentation que je vais
vous faire ce n'est pas de penser qu'à
un problème de maintien de l'ordre c'est
qu'il y a un problème l'ultra gauche
c'est pas un problème de maintien de
l'ordre des policiers c'est un problème
de violence
urbaine de guérilla qui n'a rien à voir
avec le match j'adore classique et je
pense qu'on se tromperait ça veut pas
dire qu'il faut pas améliorer toujours
le maintien de vente qui est un exercice
extrêmement ingrat et difficile mais que
il y a un moment particulier de violence
qui n'est notamment à partir du 16 mars
lorsque l'ultra gauche décide de prendre
en otage le mouvement social ou
d'accentuer
les exactions notamment de l'écologie
radicale à sainte-solide et on voit bien
que dans le petit tableau que je vous
présente évidemment ce document est à
votre disposition monsieur le Président
il y a alors qu'il y a quasiment un
million de moyenne de manifestants en
France d'ailleurs chacun souligne
l'action du préfet de police chacun son
ligne le nouveau schéma du maintien de
l'or du ministère de l'Intérieur puisque
il ne se passe pas grand chose en tout
cas du point de vue de sécurité et tant
mieux pour les manifestants et pour la
liberté de de manifester il y a très peu
de policiers blessés policiers en tout
cas ils le sont très légèrement et dans
des conditions si j'ose dire classique
d'action de manifestation nombreuses sur
le territoire et très peu
d'interpellations en tout cas par
rapport au nombre de personnes qui
manifestent
ces jours là et puis la journée qui est
en rouge c'est une journée évidemment
extrêmement important du point de vue du
changement de l'action non pas des
manifestants mais de ceux qui utilisent
ces journées comme étant des journées de
violence c'est à dire pour nous une
partie de l'ultra gauche puisque nous
avons une manifestation qui est
d'ailleurs et moins importante en nombre
que celle du 7 mars par exemple ou celle
du 31 janvier mais qui se traduit par
552 blessés chez les forces de l'ordre
rien que chez les forces de l'ordre ce
jour-là
et 428 interpellations et pourquoi parce
que c'est la présentation suivante parce
que nous documentons que l'ultra gauche
décide à partir du 16 mars d'infiltrer
le mouvement social et d'en prendre la
direction ou tenter d'en prendre la
direction je vous ai mis des citations
des notes de la DRPP d'erreur
territoriaux de la DGSI qui constitue en
effet le fait que nous avions prévu le
fait que des groupuscules des personnes
qu'elles soient françaises ou étrangères
allaient organiser contre les symboles
du capital je cite évidemment les notes
contre les forces de l'ordre contre les
institutions contre ce qui représente
l'État ou le service public des attaques
qui n'ont d'ailleurs rien à voir avec
retraite rien à voir avec l'écologie et
notamment le travail sur l'eau et
l'agriculture ces notes monsieur le
Président je le sais que vous le savez
mais je dis pour que chacun comprenne
sont à la disposition du Parlement pour
la délégation parlementaire au
renseignement
je ne peux qu'inviter la délégation
parlementaire enseignement de convoquer
les chefs de service qui sont sous ma
responsabilité de faire communiquer les
notes classées secrètes au confidentiel
elles sont nombreuses elles sont
documentées elles ont toutes dans le
même sens les élus tous les jours
évidemment de la violence de l'ultra
gauche que l'on distingue bien de la
manifestation classique bien évidemment
et d'ailleurs je veux redire que malgré
cette violence ultra gauche les
manifestations classiques se sont
quasiment toujours déroulées dans
d'excellentes conditions y compris pour
les caresses syndicaux à une exception
près notamment à Paris à Rennes et à
Nantes parce qu'on a d'ailleurs expliqué
que ça décale et d'ailleurs la
manifestation de la semaine dernière se
déroulée conformément évidemment à ce
qu'elles nous ont demandé
le depuis le 16 mars nous comptons
énormément de difficultés pour les biens
et les personnes
1851 interprétations dans toute la
France
299 atteintes contre des publics des
préfectures de sous-préfecture des
commissariats des mairies et notamment
des mairies qui n'ont rien à voir avec
la réforme des retraites ou le soutien
la réforme des retraites ce qui serait
déjà pas excusable mais qui pourrait
éventuellement s'expliquer la mairie de
Bordeaux chacun sait que sa mère Europe
Écologie Les Verts qui condamne la
réforme des retraites a été évidemment
comme chacun le sait incendié les
mairies d'arrondissement à Lyon et on
pourrait multiplier les exemples des
conseils départementaux ou des tribunaux
à Nantes qui ont été
envahi ou saccagé 132 atteintes de
permanence parlementaire et politique
33 plats demande de gouvernement ou
d'élus pour menacer outrage prix rien
que dans le giron la préfecture de
police à Paris et des dégradations
majeures de 19500 incendies de voies
publiques 58 accidents de véhicules
légers très incinant de bâtiments en une
semaine c'est un bilan extrêmement lourd
auquel a fait face des policiers
gendarmes qui traduisent le fait que ce
n'est pas la réforme des retraites qui
est en cause il est manifestants contre
la réforme des retraites mais bien des
gens qui ont voulu utiliser
ces moments de mobilisation pour
attaquer les symboles et les personnes
qui représentent la République quelques
images que vous avez vu ou par pas vu
c'est le droit n'a pas été je crois
publier très abondamment c'est le
saccage de la mairie du mairie
d'arrondissement à Lyon la photo
esthétique mais extrêmement violente de
du porche de la mairie de Bordeaux
enflammée rappelons que tous ces
manifestations y compris pour le
commissariat de Lorient et la préfecture
de Lorient euh commissariat a été
attaqué et et il a fallu d'ailleurs que
la préfecture dans ce département
en position d'attaque classique comme on
a connu au Puy-en-Velay à l'époque de la
radicalisation d'une partie des gilets
jaunes a fait de très nombreux blessés y
compris chez les sapeurs-pompiers qui
venait éteindre ses feux et si je prends
l'exemple de Bordeaux le passage la
manifestation à Bordeaux il y a eu du
monde à 18000 personnes à Bordeaux ce
jour-là c'est une grosse manifestation
sociale contre la réforme des retraites
ne passez pas dans la mairie de Bordeaux
et ce n'était pas aux horaires de la
mairie de Bordeaux c'était pas aux
horaires de la manifestation d'ailleurs
la gare de statique d'Amérique Bordeaux
avait été levée puisqu'on était tard le
soir et que évidemment ça n'a rien à
voir avec la manifestation syndicale
classique de la journée
alors
on s'est concentré sur Paris ces
derniers temps et on s'est concentré sur
l'action des services de police des
vidéos sont souvent diffusées pas
toujours favorables aux forces de
l'ordre je vais vous donner de la petite
vidéo de des forces de l'ordre qui sont
à Lyon dans une rue perpendiculaire
après la manifestation
ça dure 15 minutes comme ça
les tailles des PV sont extrêmement
impressionnants on peut passer à
d'autres sujets regarder à Dijon ou la
manifestation qui n'a rien à voir avec
celle des retraites dans une rue
perpendiculaire
ou l'ultra gauche prend à partir
extrêmement violente quelques forces de
l'ordre qui sont en faction et qui sont
de l'autre côté de la rue ils sont quand
même extrêmement nombreux
nous avons la possibilité
de voir cet immeuble parisien je voulais
dire que heureusement parfois pourquoi
les forces de l'ordre interviennent pour
protéger les biens et pourquoi ils
viennent interdire des médecins des
incendies dans cette immeuble parisien
place de l'Opéra que je fasse de l'Opéra
il y a le 23 personnes dans cet immeuble
on peut parfois agression des des
poubelles on a dû les évacuer dans de
nombreux enfants on était objectivement
à quelques minutes un drame puisque
l'immeuble commençait à prendre feu
la police a dû intervenir de façon
violente force pour mettre interpellé
les incendiaires et les sapeurs-pompiers
de Paris ont été pris à partie au début
de
de production de nombreuses personnes
interpellées c'était le cas en 2021 en
2022 de manifestations dont une
extrêmement violente a eu lieu avec déjà
500 ultra gauche black bloc et pas
forcément que français en octobre 22
avec 61 gendarmes blessés dans certains
extrêmement gravement et donc on
connaissait ce rendez-vous de sainte
Soline avec un important travail
préparatoire de notre part évidemment
qui sera soumis bien sûr aux enquêtes
judiciaires je vais d'ailleurs dire que
cette manifestation a été interdite
par la préfète des Deux-Sèvres qui à
plusieurs reprises a fait des
conférences de presse le 10 mars à écrit
aux organisateurs je mets des guillemets
le collectif passe non merci les
soulèvements de la terre mais c'est
aussi le cas la Confédération paysage
elle n'a pas eu de réponse à ses
courriers madame la préfète mais elle a
eu des communiqués de presse pour dire
que ces personnes maintenaient ces
manifestations malgré interdictions de
conférence de presse de la préfète de
des Deux-Sèvres une conférence de presse
la veille du procureur de la République
rappelant d'ailleurs aux organisateurs
c'est un point très important monsieur
le Président que c'est eux qui sont
responsables notamment des secours
chacun sait vous avez été en
responsabilité locale que c'est celui
qui organise une manifestation qu'elle
soit culturelle festive et autres que ce
sont les organisateurs qui organisent
des secours mais évidemment comme les
ordinateurs n'ont pas voulu évoquer ce
sujet et que non pas mis en place
évidemment de ce cours de secours on
reparlera tout à l'heure de de la
polémique de la fake news qui a circulé
on voit bien que le sujet était
évidemment de mettre le propre sur
l'état et ses agents plutôt que
d'organiser c'est c'est ce cours nous
avons rappelé à chacune et à chacun à sa
tombe d'interdictions malgré la
direction manifestation je pense
notamment aux arrêtés pris par Madame la
préfète pour l'interdiction de transport
d'armes sachez que cet arrêté
transportable qui semble frapper du
Creux du bon sens a été attaqué votre
tribunal par la Ligue des droits de
l'homme le tribunal administratif a
validé fort heureusement le travail de
la préfète des Deux-Sèvres mais pour
vous dire dans quel état d'esprit un
certain nombre de personnes étaient en
vue de cette manifestation je veux aussi
dire que nous avons préparé y compris au
niveau du ministère de l'Intérieur et de
moi-même par trois réunions le le
travail de la préfète et du général de
gendarmerie zonal ainsi qu'une réunion
présidée par la première ministre
elle-même le mercredi 22 mars au centre
de crise qui regroupait les ministres de
la Justice de l'intérieur de l'écologie
et de l'agriculture et de nombreux
services dans les services de
renseignement
que savions-nous nous ne savions que non
seulement il y aurait un rassemblement
extrêmement fort de personnes ultra
gauche à Sainte Soline il y avait aussi
des manifestants pacifiques d'ailleurs
une autorisation a été donnée pour la
ville de Melle Amel il y a eu une
manifestation avec plusieurs milliers de
personnes pacifiques ou les gens
pouvaient dire leur opinion évidemment
contre les bassines et il y a eu une
manifestation extrêmement violente dans
les champs à proximité des racines qui
elles n'étaient pas autorisée donc si
les gens voulaient continuer à
manifester leur opinion côté bassines
vous pouvez le faire évidemment Amel et
nous avons travaillé non seulement au
contrôle des frontières puisque les
services de renseignement allemand
italien Suisse espagnol évoqué le fait
que leur ultra gauche voulait venir à
Sainte-Soline nous avons d'ailleurs
interpellé à un certain nombre de
personnes assez frontières en prenant
des ce qu'on appelle des iat des
interdictions d'arriver sur ta
éternational par la DGSI la dpagi nous
avons fait beaucoup de contrôle
notamment autour de Sainte-Soline pour
l'arrivée je rappelle qu'il y a eu quand
même 24 000 véhicules contrôlés pendant
les trois jours qui ont précédé
deux couteaux saisis 67 boules de
pétanque 13h 5 matraques et battent de
baseball 6 bidons d'essence va aérosols
de gaz des mortiers d'artifice un moment
donc festif se préparait à Sainte-Soline
en toute pacifisme comme évidemment
chacun pourra le constater du coup 3200
policiers gendarmes et notamment des
gendarmes ont été mobilisés je rappelle
qu'à sainte-souligne il n'y avait pas il
y a pas qu'une bassine il y a plusieurs
bassines dans les Deux Sèvres qui
auraient pu être attaqués de façon
différente la concentration s'est faite
à Sainte Soline conformément
renseignement que nous avons eu mais
3200 gendarmes c'était pas que pour
s'insolin c'était pour l'ensemble du
département des Deux-Sèvres et je
voudrais rappeler ici que les armes avec
lesquelles se baladent gendarmerie ne
sont pas les armes des casseurs on me
dit qu'il y a des armes de guerre qui
ont été utilisées oui par les casseurs
la gendarmerie n'utilise pas de cocktail
Molotov par exemple vous voyez c'est pas
quelque chose que l'on peut utiliser les
drones ne sont pas autorisés par les
gendarmes je lis dans le prison de la
commission des lois une nouvelle fois
seul les policiers gendarmes ne peuvent
pas faire voler des drones en France par
contre les casseurs ont pu faire voler
des drones ça c'était une difficulté que
nous avons nous n'avons pas pu avoir une
vue totale du dispositif même sur
l'autorisation du procureur de la
République qui a refusé les demandes de
la préfète en revanche les casseurs ont
fait voler des drones pour faire
regarder le dispositif et pour ça où on
devait attaquer deuxièmement je regrette
puisqu'il me dit mais vous connaissiez
vous avez des informations pourquoi vous
avez interpellé les personnes la PPL de
Monsieur Retailleau reprise par ministre
Christophe Castaner a été censuré par le
Conseil constitutionnel et empêche le
ministre de l'Intérieur et ses services
qui ne fait aucun appliquer le droit
d'interpeller des personnes que l'on
qualifie de deux casseurs et qu'on
connaît comme tel dans une à la veille
d'une manifestation voilà pourquoi nous
nous préparions à un moment de
confrontation non pas parce que nous le
souhaitions comme je l'entends ici ou là
mais parce qu'il était inévitable
puisque personne n'a respecté l'État de
droit dans le camp des manifestants
casseurs ni les arrêtés d'interdiction
de la préfète ni les arrêter de
transport d'armes ni leur autorisé de
secours malgré tout
fini l'utilisation des images pour la
gendarmerie ni bien évidemment
de l'interdiction a priori de paraître
sur ce site qui était une propriété
privée je rappelle l'agriculteur dont
tout le monde se fiche de savoir
pourquoi leur propriété a été assez
foulée pendant des jours et des jours 60
secondes je reviendrai pas plus sur les
notes de renseignement elles sont là
aussi totalement à votre disposition
pour la délégation parmentale du
renseignement il y a eu énormément
d'objets saisis je rappelle que en plus
de ce que je vous ai cité en amont 800
objets qualifiés d'armes armes blanches
côté Molotov on a eu des chalumeaux on a
eu des tronçonneuses on a eu un certain
nombre d'objets aussi sympathiques que
cela qui ont été saisis 48 gendarmes ont
été blessés dans certains gravement et
quatre individus blessés grièvement dans
de très grièvement dont un serait encore
à lutter pour la vie on a évidemment une
pensée pour eux bien évidemment les
enquêtes judiciaires vous l'avez entendu
par le procureur de la République de
Rennes seront d'autres diront la vérité
de ce qui s'est passé dans la grande
confusion qui était essentielle je
reviens très rapidement sur la
chronologie pour vous dire que dès le
vendredi on a dû couper la ligne LGV
entre Poitiers et Angoulême parce que il
y a eu un envahissement 300 bla bloc
avait déjà attaqué les gendarmes mobiles
dès le vendredi et puis le samedi par
deux fois des cortèges de casseurs ont
attaqué à coup de cocktail Molotov et de
pierre comme on l'a tous vu à la
télévision je crois cette cette ligne de
gendarme qui protégeait je rappelle une
décision de justice
dans les Deux-Sèvres indépendamment de
ce que nous pouvons penser des bassines
ou non et du réchauffement climatique et
d'utilisation de l'eau par les
agriculteurs ce n'est pas le sujet les
gendarmes et les policiers faisaient
respecter l'interdiction de
manifestation de la gendarme de la
préfète la propriété privée pour les
agriculteurs et les décisions de justice
les policiers gendarmes ont fait
respecter l'édition de justice l'édition
de justice ont donné droit à la
construction de de sébacine évidemment
si l'opinion de chacun est supérieure
des sons de justice et du coup doit
enclencher ou non la force publique nous
ne sommes pas dans le même état droit
que nous connaissons je voudrais revenir
par contre sur un très important
peut-être pour anticiper des questions
monsieur le Président mais ça a touché
profondément l'honneur des gendarmes sur
les secours qui auraient empêché
d'intervenir les paris forces de l'ordre
j'ai d'ailleurs une question d'actualité
chez 400 rappelle dans votre assemblée
la semaine dernière
évoqué sans grande nuance je veux ici
dire d'abord que le travail
journalistique a permis de démontrer que
c'était une fake news et c'est une très
bonne chose mais il a fallu quand même
cinq jours d'insultes et et d'atteinte à
l'honneur des gendarmes pour savoir
qu'effectivement les secours n'ont pas
été empêché d'intervenir par les forces
de l'ordre un trésor 49 un premier appel
et aux données aux pompiers et à 13h50
au SAMU il faut géolocaliser ces
personnes mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs vous savez pour être élu
ruraux pour être très grande partie
d'entre vous que intervenir sur un champ
long de 6 km²
sans connaître la rue et le numéro parce
que comme ça que vous faites quand vous
appelez les pompiers ou le SMUR vous
dites voilà j'habite au 14 rue de la rue
widocchoquel à Tourcoing et je voudrais
qu'on envoie le le pompier parce que il
y a un problème déjà c'est parfois
difficile pour les secours de les
trouver mais là dire il y a un blessé
vous êtes où dans un champ entouré de
champ c'est pas très agréable quand vous
avez en plus 1000 casseurs qui se
réunissent et qui envoie des pavés et
des côtés Molotov sur la tête des
gendarmes donc il faut que géolocaliser
ce blesser nous le jurisons sans succès
le SAMU s'engage à son tour pour se
rendre sur le site avec une nouvelle
localisation indicative du PC grave il
est ralenti ce SAMU comme on l'a vu dans
les images qu'on était ensuite diffusé
soit par des blessés des parmi les
manifestants qui voulaient être soignés
soit par des personnes qui l'ont pris la
partie et devant leur capacité du SAMU
et le faire nous dessinons d'envoyer le
message de GIGN sur place entouré de
gendarmes et d'un infirmier militaire le
groupement qui accompagne le médecin du
GIGN qui fend la foule au style pour
soigner de ses graves et pris à partie
doit rebrousser le chemin le gendarme le
message GIGN à qui jouera à rendre un
hommage tout particulier malgré les jeux
de projectiles les pavés les insultes
seront auprès du du blessé prends les
premiers soins et fait le premier bilan
médical nous ne décidons une décision
même de ne pas faire évacuer par
l'hélicoptère de la gendarmerie qui
était à disposition se blesser grave
parce qu'il est blessé trop gravement et
donc on doit attendre l'hélicoptère
médicalisé du SMUR qui doit se poser
parmi la foule des images que vous avez
vu et évidemment ensuite le SAMU
c'est-à-dire si j'en crois les rapports
qui m'ont été qui ont été rendus publics
soit aussi du ministère dès le lendemain
par la DGN et par la préfète une heure
après une heure après l'appel ceci étant
dit je voudrais quand même vous montrer
ce qu'on distribuer aux manifestants
casseurs à Sainte Soline ce document qui
est très bien réalisé je pense que
beaucoup d'entre nous ne savaient pas
capables de faire ce genre de choses je
crois avec les outils informatiques
modernes c'est ce document est à votre
disposition monsieur le Président aux
membres du Parlement explique comment
réagir lorsqu'on sera blessé après la
confrontation avec les forces de l'ordre
donc d'abord comment s'équiper
évidemment ensuite il faut pas avoir que
les identité il faut pas décliner sur
les traités faut se faire enregistrer
sous X il faut pas essayer de pas être
dans près des gendarmes parce que il va
vous emmener à l'hôpital il faut pas se
présenter spontanément à l'hôpital il
faut aller à l'hôpital après et si
possible dans le département faut payer
en liquide et puis bon je vous fais la
liste évidemment il préfère passer par
le Medic Street vous savez ceux qui sont
des personnes qui auraient un diplôme
médical mais qui serait parmi les
casseurs et les manifestants bref il y a
même ensuite une petite action pour
qu'on commence déclarer les choses au
garde à vue enfin vous avez le parfait
le le parfait vadebicom avec un numéro
de téléphone d'ailleurs et précisant
d'ailleurs que sans doute la police nous
écoute a contacté via un signal au
Télégramme bref ce document qui a été
multiplié diffusé à tous les
manifestants démontrer la préméditation
comme on dit dans les services du
ministère de l'intérieur de la violence
qui allait si pénétrer et donc les
discours sur le pacifisme des
manifestants qui en tout cas sont allés
confronter les gendarmes je crois est
une fable qui n'est cru que par ceux et
encore je suis pas tout à fait certain
alors je voudrais dire la deuxième point
monsieur le Président on est en le plus
vite possible évidemment que le sujet
n'est pas la manifestation ou les
manifestations le sujet c'est pas des
bassines ou les retraites le sujet c'est
l'ultra gauche qui en Europe un filtre
des manifestations pour pouvoir être
extrêmement violente et ce n'est pas
caca français je rappelle le G20 à
Hambourg des changements se prend en
trois jours le G8 à Rostock avec des
heures pour donner lieu à plus d'un
millier de décès en Allemagne le G20 à
Londres chacun s'en souvient avec la
mort de passant mais aussi les zones à
défendre les fameuses ades en janvier
2023 il y a deux mois à l'usaz Sarthe en
Allemagne j'espère que je prononce
correctement
auxquels les policiers ont su des tirs
d'engins pyrotechnique et de protective
une centaine de blessés en janvier 23 à
Atlanta l'autre côté de l'Atlantique
pour s'opposer la construction d'une
école de police avec des morts et des
blessés bref l'ultra gauche utilise des
causes quel que soit ses causes pour
pouvoir
non pas faire faire du maintien de l'or
mais malheureusement devoir répondre à
une guerrier extrêmement violente on a
quelques images de ce qui s'est passé
voilà deux mois en Allemagne pour ceux
qui croient que ce n'est qu'en France
que les choses sont difficiles
de manifestants pour les confondues
on peut prendre aussi un exemple italien
[Applaudissements]
et je voudrais rappeler pour aller assez
vite
c'est en Italie c'est en Allemagne et
c'était il y a quelques mois ou quelques
années pour l'Italie on peut pas aussi
des cas espagnols sur la place d'amayor
bref toute l'Europe est concernée par
cette utilisation par le tragot de la
violence je rappelle d'ailleurs qu'en
France c'est pas nouveau depuis le début
des années 2000 pendant les
manifestations de CPE il y a la même
chose je rappelle que sous le
gouvernement de Monsieur Hollande
Sylvain était une forme de reptil que de
sainte Soline avec 56 gendarmes laissés
parce qu'on se rappelle tous de ce jeune
homme décédé
Notre-Dame-des-Landes 108 gendarmes
blessés je voudrais aussi rappeler
qu'entre des Landes c'était pas une un
joyeux retour et rendez-vous
d'alternatif Bontin 800 engins à s'en
dire avaient été saisi à l'époque et des
dizaines d'armes je rappelle qu'en 2016
au printemps 2016 la loi el khomri a
fait naître des contestations contre les
au travail avec une présence ultra
gauche qui avait été dénoncée par
Bernard Cazeneuve à l'époque extrêmement
forte avec un violence niveau violence
qui n'a d'ailleurs rien à voir avec ce
que nous connaissons qui était beaucoup
plus forte et je rappelle que la des
manifestations des gilets jaunes à ne
pas confondre avec le début on fait
naître aussi cette radicalisation et
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
terminerai par vous dire que ça ne fait
que commencer 42 projets sont
enregistrés par les services de
renseignement comme étant ceux qui
peuvent faire des contestations
extrêmement violentes
dont 17 avec une radicalisation du
niveau de s'insoline au minimum le
prochain sera sans doute l'autoroute
entre Toulouse et Castres qui posera
d'énormes d'ailleurs de de difficultés
pour les pour les forces de l'ordre il y
a des choses qui peuvent éventuellement
se comprendre du point de vue écologique
même si ça se comprend pas du point de
vue d'État droit je pense à l'extension
de l'aéroport de Lille ou la
construction du canal du du lion de
Turin par exemple mais il y a aussi des
causes tout à fait écologiques qui sont
l'objet de ces contestations en
violentes je pense aux lignes LGV par
exemple qui sont tout aussi contestés
que les constructions d'autoroute donc
je voudrais vous persuader ici que le
sujet n'est pas tellement l'objet de la
contestation mais la contestation
elle-même contre les institutions
républicaines enfin très vite parce que
on en a beaucoup parlé pendant la locmi
le gouvernement a tiré des conclusions
des difficultés précédentes mais il faut
évidemment le temps que cela se fasse
c'est bien sûr le nouveau schéma de
maintien de l'ordre qui a été validé par
le Conseil d'État c'est la première fois
qu'il est écrit et validé par le Conseil
d'État c'est la formation qui a rajouté
4 mois c'est le nouveau centre
opérationnel qui serait opération en
2024 d'entraînement par la préfecture de
police à Villeneuve-Saint-Georges le
terrain d'ailleurs été acheté au
ministère des armées depuis la loi votée
c'est évidemment la fin d'un certain
nombre de Grenade notamment de grenades
explosif qui ne sont plus utilisés
depuis l'année dernière par les forces
de police et de et de gendarmerie c'est
évidemment la clarification des
sommations le travail qu'on doit
toujours continuer à faire avec les
manifestants et surtout les journalistes
évidemment je lis ici ou là que les Nass
ou l'action du maintien de l'ordre de la
préfecture de police serait contraire au
Droit dont les nats souhaitaient
validées par le Conseil d'État
simplement il y a des conditions qui
sont évidemment
appliquées par les préfets je le
rappellerai dans vos questions si vous
le si vous le souhaitez voilà en
quelques mots monsieur le Président je
viens pas sur les moyens vous avez voté
par le pays vous les connaissez il est
sûr qu'il manque des unités de force
mobile entre pays je voudrais dire que
dès le mois de juin cette unités de
gendarmerie mobile auront été créés et
présents d'ailleurs pour cet été trois
unités de CRS conformément à l'autre
mise seront créés pour le mois d'octobre
et une quatrième pour le mois de mars
prochain
merci Monsieur le Ministre alors
j'ai 14 demande d'intervention au moment
où je vous parle donc je vous invite à
ce qu'on respecte bien les deux minutes
chacun ou chacune mais le directeur de
la commission est là pour rappeler
l'heure et moi pour éteindre les micros
on en est pas là chacun fera ça la liste
est la suivante pardon le maintien de
l'ordre
débuteront pas Monsieur Alain Marc puis
monsieur Guy benaroche Monsieur François
bonhomme monsieur Marc libourresse je
suis Jérôme Durand Monsieur Philippe Bas
madame Benbassa
j'ai vu un bracelet tout à l'heure
[Musique]
madame l'herbier monsieur Jean-Yves
Lecomte et madame haribet je prends dans
l'ordre des marins levés je ne regarde
pas autrement monsieur Lamarque pour 2
minutes merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre cette audition est
l'occasion de de dire mon soutien absolu
aux forces de l'ordre en réalité c'est
la violence de certains faits qui a été
mise en exergue par les médias alors que
globalement les choses sont finalement
pas trop trop mal passées les violences
elles étaient contre les institutions de
la République et par une étrange
inversion des valeurs ce sont les
policiers et gendarmes qui se trouvent
mis en accusation
à mes yeux c'est parfaitement
inadmissible et comme on dit chez nous
il faut parfois remettre les choses à
l'endroit vous le faites aujourd'hui
d'autre part lorsque l'on participe à
une à une manifestation qui est
interdite et bien écoutez on sait les
risques que l'on prend monsieur le
ministre comment souhaitez-vous que nous
puissions faire évoluer notre droit afin
que nos policiers et gendarmes ne soient
pas aussi démunis et puisse plus
aisément
usé de la force légitime
je vais la roche
oui monsieur le ministre j'ai envie de
vous dire qu'une femme en vaut une autre
et qu'en fait c'est clair pour vous ce
n'est pas un problème de matière de
l'ordre vous l'avez expliqué très
clairement mais c'est une guérilla qui
s'ouvre et donc vous déclarez la guerre
et bien entendu pour déclarer la guerre
faut accuser l'agresseur faut accuser
d'être agressé c'est classique c'est
clair vous la on l'a vu en fait c'est
une preuve claire tout ce qui a été
votre vous savez monsieur le ministre
que tous les projets de bassine ont été
déboutés dans tous les recours en
justice qui démontent leur non
conformité avec les législation
française et européenne vous savez
monsieur ludis que vous avez modifié
votre doctrine du vatia de l'ordre
depuis le 16 mars les chiffres prouvent
c'est pas que les manifestants qui ont
changé c'est vos doctrines qui ont été
modifiées depuis le 16 mars vous savez
monsieur le ministre que ce qui s'est
passé lors des récentes manifestations à
cette souligne en particulier ne relève
pas uniquement de bavure d'un tel ou
Intel il y a des enquêtes en cours mais
de l'application destruction et de
coïncides qui ont été donnée avec de
nouvelles doctrines de matières de
lampes par votre ministère vous savez
bien monsieur Louise qui a un certain
nombre de faits qui seront mis en
exergue compris qu'ils ont été depuis 15
jours et sur lesquels vous-même vous
êtes revenus sur des affirmations que
vous aviez fait au début et que les
instructions au cours les enquêtes en
cours votre rend parfaitement bien un
certain nombre de choses donc je vais
poser ma question très brièvement
l'article Hertz 3112 du code de la
sécurité intérieure définit les armes
classées selon les catégories monsieur
le ministre je vais pas les reprendre au
quatrième cinquième paragraphe on
retrouve les loges grenades de tout
calibre et los projectiles les systèmes
de projection spécifiquement est
destinés à l'usage militaire ou au
métier de l'ordre ainsi que l'ambition
ce type de matériel a-t-il été utilisé à
cette solide monsieur le ministre
deuxièmement des grenades lacrymogènes
ont-elles étaient lancées vers des élus
avec leurs écharpes et en tel était
lancée en direction des blessés loin des
zones dehors c'est mes deux questions
bien entendu se termine en disant que
tout comme vous tous les dégâts qui ont
été causés et chez les manifestants et
dans les forces de police sont liés à
vos processus d'escalade au lieu de
désescalade vous savez le suivi qu'en
France
le nombre de morts et de blessés lors
des manifestations et quatre fois
supérieur à la moyenne et à chacun des
pays européens monsieur le ministre d'où
la compréhension du monde vis-à-vis de
ce qui se passe en France merci Monsieur
benaroche Merci monsieur François
bonhomme
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre
dimanche il y a quelques jours nous
avons assisté à un déchaînement sans
doute sans précédent de violence
sans limite qui s'est exprimée à Sainte
Soline et en dépit de tous les
détracteurs sur le nom respect de l'État
de droit l'État de droit à globalement
été respecté la série fondamentale vous
avez rappelé dans votre présentation
générale toutes les voies de recours qui
ont pu être épuisées ou non utilisé en
tout cas qui ont permis d'agir dans la
pure légalité donc il n'y a pas de sujet
là dessus vous avez rappelé également le
travail préparatoire du préfet du
procureur et tout le travail de contrôle
en amont qui peut être réalisé pour
prévenir les troubles donc tout cela ne
fait pour moi aucune sujet de discussion
donc à partir de là contrairement à ce
qu'on dit dans notre collègue benaroche
parler de promeneur pacifique des gens
qui sont équipés de boules de pétanque
de battes de baseball de bidon d'essence
de bonbonne de gaz de mortier d'artifice
ou d'armes blanches et encore de
cocktail monotov il faudra beaucoup
d'énergie et beaucoup de croyances pour
nous faire croire que c'était des grands
donneurs du dimanche ou des manifestants
pacifiques donc ça n'a rien à voir une
manifestation classique et nous avons
vraiment eu l'occasion d'assister à une
volonté claire d'affrontement avec les
forces de l'ordre
les conditions par ailleurs de maintien
de l'ordre ont été parfaitement
respectés
effectivement des tentatives non pas des
fake news je dirais des bobards parce
que c'est plus français et des fausses
informations qui ont été tentées de
diffuser y compris sur les personnes qui
auraient été empêchées d'avoir les
premiers secours et en dépit je dois le
dire de tous les observateurs des
pratiques policières autoproclamés
issus de la Ligue des droits de l'homme
et d'autres associations ou des
défenseurs des droits auto saisis je
rappelle quand même que ça pose une
question le Défenseur des droits est
financé par fonds publics à une statut
indépendant et surtout saisie comme bien
lui semble c'est le présent République
qui l'a désigné et maintenant il ne peut
que se mordre les doigts de la pratique
qu'elle a de sa mission je rappelle
deuxième chose Monsieur le Ministre que
la ligne droite de l'homme Ligue des
droits de l'homme par antiphrase et
financé sur fond public y compris de
l'État donc si vous voulez être cohérent
monsieur le ministre il faut cesser de
financer des associations qui non
seulement mettent en cause gravement
l'État avec un état violent policier
dans un état policier qui est toujours
dénoncé une violence systémique et je
sais qu'à par ailleurs vous avez dénoncé
l'analyse et par ailleurs c'est tout un
mixité de l'État on finance ses
associations qui n'ont rien à voir avec
l'État de droit quoi qu'elles en disent
alors la question un dernier élément
monsieur le ministre c'est l'ambiguïté
de votre propos parce que tout le reste
je suis d'accord c'est que l'État est
n'est pas cohérent et parfois même
ambigu on a vous avez pas de Stevens 6
vins ça a été abandonné par un arrêté un
arrêté préfectoral à la demande de la
question
on a arrêté Notre-Dame-des-Landes en
février 2018 alors même qu'il y avait
une consultation publique en février en
juin 2016 qui a confirmé le projet donc
que l'État aujourd'hui s'étonne après
que on encourage d'une certaine façon
tous les contestataires de Tool qui veut
mettre qui veulent mettre la-bas il ne
faut pas s'étonner que un moment donné
cette ambiguïté nous ramène à la figure
monsieur Marc Philippe de Bresse oui
monsieur le ministre bien sûr nous
partageons le diagnostic et les
objectifs de ce que vous venez de nous
dire avec force argument à l'appui et je
rappelle que la majorité sénatoriale a
écrit une résolution qui exprime sa
gratitude et ça reconnaissant aux forces
de l'ordre nul besoin de le dire ici il
y a une très large majorité pour
partager ce point de vue vous le savez
et nous l'avons démontré puisque dans
toutes les lois auxquelles nous avons
participé avec mes collègues et moi
comme rapporteur avec d'autres nous
avons soutenu les moyens nécessaires
pour le ministère de l'Intérieur la
question que je voudrais sur laquelle je
voudrais aller directement vous avez dit
dans le Journal du Dimanche plus aucune
ZAD ne s'installera dans notre pays ni à
sainte-solide ni ailleurs nous créerons
une cellule antisèle avec des jurys
spécialisés évidemment que nous sommes
interpellés je prolonge que disait mon
collègue François bonhomme quand la
Ligue des droits de l'Homme conteste un
arrêté préfectoral qui prévoit
d'interdire des armes la destination sur
Sainte Soline on peut se poser des
questions il y a un certain nombre de
décisions du Conseil constitutionnel qui
ont été prises sur les drones il y a
tous et tous ces sujets là donc à quel
niveau voulez-vous agir est-ce que vous
avez créé une cellule juridique avec des
moyens est-ce qu'on doit aller dans des
projets de loi est-ce que vous nous
associerez à ces projets de loi pour
qu'on travaille sur un arsenal et des
outils juridiques plus appropriés pour
qu'on cesse de de tolérer la tolérable
et donc de justifier l'injustifiable et
est-ce que vous avez aussi réfléchi au
niveau constitutionnel merci monsieur le
ministre monsieur Jérôme Durand merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre alors je voudrais débiter
débuter en rappelant que que à titre
personnel et au nom de mon groupe nous
soutenons les forces de l'ordre nous
condamnons les violences des casseurs
nous avons voté la loopi ce qui devrait
nous éviter et nous n'avons pas grand
chose à voir avec l'ultra gauche ce qui
devrait nous éviter pour la suite de mon
propos tout procès en terror
intellectuel alors le sujet n'est pas le
talent du ministre ou son efficacité
politique c'est reconnu par la par la
presse c'est plutôt son bilan en matière
de maintien de l'ordre du Stade de
France au rue de Paris ou de Bordeaux
forcer de constater que nous constatons
trop de dysfonctionnement et tout n'est
pas toujours de la faute des autres les
manifestants les supporters des clubs de
football étrangers les membres de
l'ultra à droite ou l'ultra gauche il y
aura tout le temps des gens qui voudront
causer des désordres le maintien de
l'ordre c'est fait pour ça alors quel
retour d'expérience autocritique on peut
avoir aujourd'hui monsieur le ministre
sur cette action parce que on est piégé
dans un débat et d'ailleurs une certaine
partie de mes collègues de droite dans
une hémiplégie sécuritaire oublie que
l'État de droit c'est la liberté et la
sécurité et on est convoqué dans un
débat très binaire avec les méchants les
gentils on l'avait sur l'immigration
c'est importer maintenant dans le champ
de la sécurité alors oui il y a les
méchants black bloc et oui il y a plutôt
des gentils policiers ceci étant cette
vision en noir et blanc elle ne
contribue pas l'efficacité de l'action
publique alors quelques questions très
contraintes très très concrètes afin de
faciliter la désescalade un principe
d'importance pour les polices de
beaucoup de pays voisins qui ont eux
aussi à gérer des troubles d'importance
soit vous entendre sur deux points le
Rio et l'imagerie d'extrême droite le
Conseil d'État doit rendre aujourd'hui
sa décision concernant l'obligation de
porter le numéro d'identification cette
question qui pourrait paraître
accessoire ne l'est pas pour deux
raisons d'abord l'identification des
policiers intervenants dans le cadre des
opérations de maintien de l'ordre
apporte beaucoup notamment s'il faut
retracer la chaîne des responsabilités
en cas de manquement déontologique
ensuite cela est perçu à raison par la
population comme une évidence que l'on
puisse
identifier les policiers la représente
la représentante du Ministère de
l'Intérieur indiquait que le non coord
du Rio n'empêchait pas l'identification
des policiers suspectés de fautes
pendant des manifestations pourtant de
nombreux enquêtes de l'IGPN sont
classées sans suite faute d'avoir pu
identifier les auteurs des manquements
alors que comptez-vous faire monsieur le
ministre pour augmenter le port du Rio
au-delà des rappels de cette obligation
il y en a eu 18 depuis 2013 par ailleurs
certains policiers rechignent apporter
leur Rio mais d'autres tiennent au
contraire à portée des symboles
empruntés à l'extrême droite alors c'est
la fine Blue Line et cuisson Georges
dread Umbrella Corporation ou John Wick
accompagné de certaines mentions pour
vous faire un tel rappel aujourd'hui à
la tension des forces de l'ordre pour
dire que police et gendarmerie que c'est
totalement illégal et votre position de
ministre de l'Intérieur donnerait une
force particulière à cette déclaration
et puis je termine par un propos de
Nicolas Lerner qui est directeur de la
DGSI qui dit c'est un peu pour tempérer
l'ambiance du moment nombre démocratie
occidentale considèrent que la menace
d'ultra droite suprématiste accélère
rationniste est aujourd'hui la
principale menace à laquelle elles sont
confrontées merci merci Monsieur durant
monsieur le questeur Philippe Bas
merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre cheval à la parole
monsieur le ministre je vous remercie
des informations que vous nous avez
apporté sur
les récences événements de sainte Soline
vous le savez le Sénat est depuis de
longues années a toujours été aux côtés
de l'État pour que force reste à la loi
face à tous ceux qui préfèrent l'action
violente plutôt que de s'en remettre
à la démocratie au dialogue social
et nous restons dans cet état d'esprit
disponible et prêt à prendre des
initiatives pour que l'État sache se
déforme
ce matin il y avait un Matignon une
grande réunion sociale elle a tourné
court
et je vois je dois quand même vous dire
que le gouvernement auquel vous
appartenez n'est pas capable de produire
du consensus social sur ces réformes et
que dès lors il ne faut pas s'étonner
qu'il y ait dans notre pays une forme de
radicalisation des luttes
vous n'êtes pas non plus capable de
contenir l'ultra gauche
on a évoqué
[Musique]
Sivas on a évoqué
Notre-Dame-des-Landes enfin il y a eu
aussi l'Arc de Triomphe les gilets
jaunes le Stade de France c'est autre
chose des manifestations récentes que
vous avez rappelées avec des incendies
d'ordures des violences Paris Rennes
Nantes et au fond tout ce que vous nous
avez démontré montre que ce qui s'est
produit était prévisible
qu'avez-vous fait pour l'empêcher
c'était interdit mais où est l'autorité
de l'État quand l'interdiction n'est pas
respectée et que vous ne vous donnez pas
les moyens d'empêcher ce que vous
interdisez là je crois que nous sommes
face au limites de votre propre action
quand tes forces de l'ordre rentre en
jeu il est normal
qu'elles utilisent la force pour
laquelle elles sont justement employées
et je crois que il est important pour
nous de les défendre de souligner la
difficulté de leur mission et de les
appuyer mais il me semble que nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans une situation où
l'État est défié certes mais qu'il est
aussi peut-être déficient pour faire
face à ce type de difficulté et je
voudrais savoir de quoi avez-vous besoin
maintenant pour que ça ne se reproduise
pas
merci professeur merci alors encore deux
intervenants sont les intervenantes
madame Benbassa au nom de la Gontrie je
laisserai la parole au ministre et on
reprendra ensuite la liste madame
Benbassa merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre depuis une semaine
vous parlez des côtes terrorisme de
terrorisme intellectuel tous ces abus de
langage sont dans un premier temps une
offense à la mémoire des victimes
d'attentat et dans un second temps une
incitation à la violence grand
cesserez-vous c'est provocation qui loin
de calmer le débat ne font que l'on veut
Numer et pour la même occasion je vous
poserai une deuxième question vous
parlez abondamment de l'extrême gauche
mais très peu de l'extrême droite je
voudrais
par cette occasion vous parlez de
groupuscules qui s'appelle fr DTR que
vous avez
dissous je le sais qui a repris une
liste qui avait été produite par
Français de souche il y a 2 ans je crois
et qui appelle à des actes de violence
en passant par télégramme à des actes de
violence contre les contre des
personnalités qui figurent et des élus
et j'en fais partie et j'ai peur je vous
le dis alors qu'est-ce que vous comptez
faire contre ce genre de groupuscules
merci Madame Bassa
merci président monsieur le ministre
vous avez à plusieurs reprises
regrettées on peut le comprendre ce que
beaucoup maintenant appellent désormais
grâce à Donald Trump les fake news et
vous avez raison mais vous avez depuis
le début de ce cette séquence vous-même
contribuez à cette situation et donc je
voulais savoir comment vous envisagiez
la suite de vos déclarations vous avez
dit le 21 mars et vous l'avez répété le
28 mars être dans une manifestation non
déclarée est un délit nous savons tout
ce qu'il n'en est rien et cela a été
rappelé y compris par le Conseil d'État
vous avez indiqué le 27 mars concernant
la brave m que cette la section de la
brave m qui avait été mise en cause dans
les événements sur lequel on peut
revenir mais je n'ai pas le temps dans
les deux minutes
avait été écarté tout en disant dans une
ce qu'on pourrait qualifier d'oxymore
ils n'ont pas été identifiés
formellement mais il m'a été confirmé
qui ne serait pas engagée dans la
manifestation de mardi ce qui était
quand même un tour de force et enfin
vous avez indiqué ainsi que votre préfet
de police que il y avait ce qu'on
pourrait appeler un signalement
automatique des violences filmées et
quand on se renseigne auprès de la
préfecture il s'avère qu'il n'y a aucun
service sur ce point et que de fait
malgré l'activité sur les réseaux
sociaux il n'y a pas de dispositif dédié
qui permettent d'identifier les dérives
des forces de l'ordre donc je vous
interroge pour savoir comment vous
entendez y répondre et puis je vous ai
posé une question d'actualité mercredi
dernier à laquelle sur un point vous
n'avez pas répondu donc je suis
quelqu'un de obstiné
vous avez vous avez fait la une du JDD
je vous en félicite sans doute en
indiquant que vous refusiez de céder au
terrorisme intellectuel de l'extrême
gauche ether ben Bassa a parfaitement
rappelé je suis élu de Paris le terme de
terrorisme pour français d'ailleurs et
quelque chose que vous ne devriez pas
utiliser de manière un peu rapide mais
je vous demandais lors des dernières
questions d'actualité si vous étiez prêt
à adresser aux membres des forces de
l'ordre la lettre que le préfet Grimaud
avait envoyé le 29 mai 68 à l'ensemble
des de ces agents qui disaient je dis la
phrase la plus marquante frappée un
manifestant tomber à terre c'est se
frapper soi-même en apparaissant sous un
jour qui atteint toute la fonction
policière vous ne m'avez pas répondu je
ne pense pas que vous considérez que le
préfet Grimaud pratiqué le terrorisme
intellectuel je rappelle qu'à la
préfecture de police de Paris une salle
d'ailleurs a été dénommée en honneur du
préfet
alors je vais de la parole au ministre
pour cette première partie de réponse et
puis nous redébuterons dès que
l'intention est terminée par Monsieur
bonne Carrère
bien merci beaucoup j'ai peut-être de
commencer par répondre à madame la
sénatrice
quel est le Conseil d'État sur la
manifestation c'est que j'ai dit une
incision mais ce n'était pas faux je
rappelle madame satrice vous faites la
loi que une manifestation
interdite
qui n'est pas déclaré prévu depuis le
décalois de 1935 et désormais l'article
elle 211 est suivant fait que si on
organise manifestation non déclaré ou
interdite cela constitue en effet un
délit l'Artic 431 9 du Code pénal 6 mois
d'emprisonnement participer si vous me
laissez terminer vous allez voir je suis
sûr que vous verrez une cohérence ça va
penser en tout cas je l'espère donc
d'abord organiser mes faisceaux c'est un
délit participer à une manifestation
interdite c'est une infraction punie de
la contravention de quatrième classe et
constituée un rassemblement de personnes
sur la République dans un lieu public se
situe de trouver l'ordre public
notamment lorsque le manifestation est
interdite 431 3 c'est aussi un délit
donc je peut-être évoquer le fait que
vous n'encouragez pas à manifester alors
j'aimerais que vous puissiez m'écouter
madame la sénatrice et ben vous puissiez
m'écouter est-ce que en effet si vous ne
m'écoutez pas vous risquez pas de
m'entendre même si vous n'êtes pas
d'accord avec moi ensuite pardon mais
tout ce que vous avez dit Madame la
madame vous la première ministre ce que
je me plaise madame la sénatrice il faut
permettez-moi juste de corriger votre
propos sans doute en début de langage
sur votre préfet de police j'ai senti à
la fois du mépris et une insulte pour le
préfet de police peut-être le préfet de
police de la République ce serait une
bonne chose je je suppose que serait une
autre chose à respecter les
fonctionnaires qui sont pas là et qui
sont pas là pour vous répondre donc le
préfet de police la bravem oui les 5
individus qui sont soupçonnés d'avoir
été dans l'enregistrement audio que nous
avons entendu et qui était évidemment
scandaleux n'ont pas été sur la voie
publique parmi ces cinq nous ne savons
pas encore exactement qui des deux
personnes ont parlé donc tout à fait ils
n'ont pas été sur la publicité parmi
c'est ça qui n'ont pas été totalement
identifiés une enquête administrative
deuxièmement vous et c'est très
intéressant que j'ai pas le droit
d'utiliser le mot le mot terrorisme mais
vous n'êtes pas la police des mots
madame de La Gontrie c'est justement ça
une partie de ce que c'est de faire la
police de la pensée le camp du Bien
comme dirait Philippe muret au fait
partie manifestement du camp du Bien et
vous vous considérez qu'il y a des gens
qui peuvent utiliser des mots et
d'autres qui peuvent pas le faire il n'y
a pas de police des mots démocratie
madame la sédatrice et vous n'avez pas
la panache ni de la morale ni du
vocabulaire je mets des mots sur les
choses jeter des cocktails Motors sur
des gendarmes c'est de la terreur parce
que vous n'avez jamais été parmi les
jardins pour recevoir des cocktails
Molotov c'est pas mieux moi je vous
encourage demain matin plutôt que
d'évoquer l'honneur de la police
gendarmerie jetez parfois au chien comme
on aurait dit un ancien président de la
République passer une journée avec
Abraham pour voir ce qu'il toute la
journée ils ont comme violence en face
de une journée de la FP l'a demandé il
est allé il est revenu je crois
impressionner
BFM l'a demandé pour ses confuserait je
pense que tous les Français ont vu ce
que c'était alors poste de télévision
d'ailleurs le journaliste a été blessé
n'hésitez pas moi j'encourage demain je
vous donne rendez-vous si vous le
souhaitez évidemment c'est total liberté
là vous venez à 8h du matin à 7h du
matin on prend toute la journée parmi
les manifestations n'hésitez pas
n'hésitez pas à venir malheureusement je
constate que c'est plus facile de le
faire de loin que de le faire de près
auprès d'eux c'est dommage parce que
comme la très bien dit moi je vous
encourage vous avez lu le JDD c'est vous
avez des bonnes lectures le dimanche
manifestement mais je vous encourage à
écouter Bernard Cazeneuve ce matin sur
France Inter
mais c'était je crois extrêmement
intéressant et ça permettait de
constater en effet qu'il y avait sur
notre dans notre République évidemment
et bien évidemment une gauche qui
soutient les forces de l'ordre n'est pas
oui mais pour les forces de l'ordre je
te donnerai par dire madame je
reviendrai pour vous monsieur le
sénateur je vais pas dire pour gribo
vous comparez mes 68 vous savez qu'il y
a eu 7 morts 68 madame la sénatrice vous
savez qu'il y a eu 2000 blessés dont
plus de 400 très gravement entre 200 et
400 très gravement vous comparez
l'incomparable et c'est ça une forme
aussi c'est ça c'est une forme de police
des mots vous comparez des choses qui
n'ont rien à voir Madame madame la
sénatrice voilà donc je crois que un peu
un peu de un peu de modération pour les
propos et de soutien aux forces de
l'ordre je pense que c'est ça la
personne ce sont des gens vous savez
qu'une partie d'entre eux qui vous ont
abandonné électoralement il faut vous
demander pourquoi peut-être parce que
vous ne les défendez pas au moment ils
sont attaqués et que vous mettez un
signe égal madame la satrice entre la
police la gendarmerie et les cast il n'y
a pas de sinégal parce que oui mais tu
as un signe égale intellectuellement il
n'y a pas de signes il y a pas de
il y a pas de vous dites les violences
de qui viennent des enfants qui viennent
les blessés de qui viennent il y a pas
de Sénégal parce qu'il y en a qui ont la
force il y en a qui en a qui ont la
force du droit et de la loi que vous
élaborez et il y en a qui n'ont pas la
force du droit et de la loi et
qu'utilise la violence tout court et
c'est extrêmement différent et je pense
qu'il faut rappeler les choses et je je
je
suis personnellement très touché quand
je vois des policiers des gendarmes qui
se sentent par des discours politiques
comme les vôtres insultés voilà moi ce
que je vous dis très très franchement
pour répondre
à Monsieur à Monsieur Durin
pour répondre à Monsieur Durand vous
avez raison sur l'autocritique que l'on
doit faire évidemment alors si jamais il
est très à chaud vous savez bien parce
que l'on peut tirer des conclusions de
tout cela on en a tiré du Stade de
France vous l'évoquez je pense que je
suis même expliqué et d'ailleurs il y a
eu de très nombreuses événements au
Stade de France d'ailleurs vous n'avez
pas fait la Une de votre commission
parce que ça s'est très bien passé y
compris d'ailleurs pendant les
manifestations on a eu le weekend à
sainte-solide un grand match de l'équipe
de France au Stade de France et des
manifestations violentes et les choses
se sont très correctement passées je
m'en félicite donc oui il y a des il y a
des critiques à faire comme toute chose
bien évidemment on en tira les
conclusions comme j'ai dit j'ai publié
les rapports les RETEX et je le ferai
comme il a eu au lendemain silence il y
avait des choses à améliorer cela cela
cela a été fait vous évoquez alors je
passe rapidement vous dites il y a pas
que des méchants et des gentilles il y a
des gens qui policiers des méchants
Black Bloc la différence c'est que il y
a pas de gentil Black Bloc ça je pense
que on peut se mettre d'accord ensemble
donc il y a quand même un peu des gens
qui qui sont plus gentils que d'autres
quand même le dire je veux dire au
passage mais je sais que que vous le
savez j'apprécie l'introduction que vous
avez eu pour les forces de l'ordre mais
je n'en doutais évidemment absolument
pas et eux non plus sur le rio vous avez
raison alors aujourd'hui le Conseil
d'État se prononce en référé donc il y
aurait des décisions au fond quelque
soit cette décision vous avez raison il
y a des positions qui portent pas leur
immatriculation bah c'est effectivement
au contraire aux règles vous avez
rappelé vous-même d'ailleurs qu'il y a
eu beaucoup de rappels aux règles
faut-il aller plus loin écoutez on va y
réfléchir si le Conseil d'État considère
qu'il nous faut nous engendre de le
faire bon mais vous avez raison par
ailleurs qu'il faut absolument les
identifier pour pouvoir sanctionner
lorsque ces personnes ne sont pas ne
sont pas évoquées donc moi je vais
attendre la décision du Conseil d'État
et comme toujours avec le droit parce
que je suis républicain démocrate
j'appliquerai les règles de droit et me
plaisent me plaisent pas et je fais de
la politique parfois pour les changer
c'est vrai comme vous d'ailleurs mais
quand elles existent et quels sont
décidées par la majorité je les
appliquerai on verra ce que dirait le
Conseil d'État c'est qu'on c'est l'état
effectivement me le fait remarquer nous
prendrons d'autres dispositions et je
suis prêt d'ailleurs à vous y associer
si vous le souhaitez et vous avez raison
il ne peut pas y avoir de rupture de la
neutralité des agents du service public
en général et donc des policiers déjà en
particulier qui parèrentont un rôle
particulier aucune démonstration
politique philosophique et encore moins
bien évidemment qui relèverait de
l'ultra droite je vois beaucoup de
policiers gendarmes comme vous
permettez-moi de penser que depuis 3 ans
j'en vois peut-être encore davantage de
façon organisée et de façon surprise
quel que soit les policiers gendarmes il
m'est arrivé de constater dans des cas
très minimes qu'il y avait en effet des
personnes qui portaient des signes
qui n'étaient pas des signes que nous
pourrions accepter de manière générale
on doit pas porter des signes sur son
uniforme c'est un cas extrêmement réduit
mais vous avez raison ils peuvent
exister et à chaque fois j'ai fait
prendre des sanctions et oui les signes
qui relèveraient de l'ultra droite ou de
l'extrême droite ne sont évidemment en
aucun cas à tolérer et non seulement ils
doivent être tirés mais ces personnes
doivent être sanctionnées j'ai le cas
d'ailleurs d'un policier voilà quelques
semaines qui
participer dans sa vie civile à aimer
manifestation de l'extrême droite avec
des slogans qui ont été évidemment
confondus par les images puis qui se
s'est retrouvé parmi des gens d'extrême
droite ultra-droite pour pouvoir faire
une manifestation violente que nous
avons arrêté il y a quelques semaines de
ça encadre justement des en marge de la
Coupe du monde notamment des contre des
supporters je mets évidemment des
guillemets nous les avons tous
interpellés c'est exaction d'appel lieu
parce que la police c'est son travail et
ne distingue pas le droit à gauche de la
droite elle attaque tous ceux qui
s'attaquent à la République et cette
personne a été révoquée et je vais vous
dire était révoqué en plus à l'unanimité
du conseil de discipline c'est à dire
vraiment y compris la raison syndicale
donc vous allez raison ça peut arriver
comme dans tout métier il y a des
gardiens de phares des boulangers des
sénateurs des policiers des gendarmes
qui peuvent faire des bêtises qui
peuvent être inquiétées par la justice
qui peuvent parfois des choses
contraires aux règles et doivent être
sortis de ce corps social et vous avez
parfaitement raison non nous ne
considérons pas que la menace principale
et l'ultra gauche une image principale
en France terroriste et bien évidemment
la menace islamiste 40 à 41 attentats
déjoué depuis 2017 encore un sans doute
hier grâce au service de renseignement
il y a eu 9 attentat déjouer de l'ultra
droite depuis 2017 dont certains depuis
que je suis ministre de l'Intérieur et
là encore la délégation d'enseignement
pourrait vous donner toutes les
informations et on a quand même eu un
ultra gauche à la fin de de l'année 2020
une action extrêmement violente
mortifère contre des forces de l'ordre
c'est perso ont été mis en examen
présenteusement un juge et incarcéré je
constate qu'on en parle pas oui il y a
aussi menace ultra gauche à 2200 ultra
gauche fiches par la DGSI et il y en a
un petit millier pour l'ultra droite il
y en a plus de 20000 pour les islamistes
il ne faut pas comparer je pense que il
faut pas faire croire que d'un côté
alors la gauche j'irai vous oubliez de
l'extrême droite elle a le droit de dire
à gauche les extrêmes ne sont bons pour
personne et les abattre la République de
la même manière certains par la race
d'autres parlent revendications radicale
sociale elles sont et même tous les deux
au pire et non les services amateurs ne
choisit pas entre deux ultras elle les
combats de la même manière mais je sais
que vous en êtes convaincus je vais dire
au ministre bas que si je comprends sa
question je me permettrai de tempérer je
dois lui rappeler que
Notre-Dame-des-Landes ça date pas
d'Emmanuel Macron et que je constate que
ça fait très longtemps depuis les années
70 qu'on essaie de faire un aéroport de
landes et puis compris sur les
gouvernements que vous avez servi
monsieur le ministre ou que vous avez
soutenu lorsque vous n'étiez pas
responsabilité on n'a pas évacué les
personnes qui s'occupent illégalement
des terrains comment ça à mettre des
pieds attaquer des policiers légendaires
donc vous avez raison mais je pense que
c'est ce que je dis d'ailleurs dans le
journal la lâcheté par habitude par peur
par complaisance intellectuelle a été
très collective vis-à-vis d'ultra gauche
très collective et il faut mettre fin à
ça et donc ce que j'ai dit dans le
Journal du Dimanche c'est qu'il y aura
plus de mètres qui s'installeront
qu'est-ce qu'on voulait faire dans les
bassines c'est là aussi je ne suis pas
d'accord avec vous pour votre opinion
mais j'ai entendu l'introduction de
Monsieur Bonhomme c'est qu'il voulait
faire une ZAD
on dit souvent vous avez mis des
gendarmes pour protéger un trou c'est
pas l'objet d'abord quand bien même
c'est une mission de justice et c'est
une propriété mais c'est pas ça l'objet
l'objet est encore les notes de
renseignement vous l'apprendront sans
doute encore plus précisément il voulait
faire une zadine enfin la même chose
contre un des Landes d'ailleurs le
collectif Les soulèvement de la terre ce
sont des anciens très différentes
parties d'entre eux qui ont appris de
Notre-Dame-des-Landes et qui faisait
partie Notre-Dame-des-Landes et elasa en
tant que telle elle est insupportable
puisque c'est une zone de non-droit mais
en plus elle crée des cellules souches
pardon pour d'autres contestations et
d'autres violences parfois des
contre-sociétés la déscolarisation des
enfants on en parle pas assez mais il y
a une partie du train à gauche qui met
en place l'emprise m'a demandé conseils
municipaux où on fait démissionner des
mers dans certains départements
notamment du sud-ouest de notre pays il
faut il faut vraiment comprendre que
c'est une organisation et oui nous
essayons de rompre avec une forme de
l'acheter ou de complaisance qui a eu
avec l'ultra gauche est-ce qu'on a été
responsable sans doute tous les hommes
les femmes je pense de ces 30 dernières
années parce qu'ils n'ont pas voulu
aller à la confrontation parce que
évidemment après il y a des violences
évidemment après on vient se justifier
devant vous monsieur le sénateur je
pense qu'on est arrivé à un point
extrêmement critique et c'est un point
européen c'est pas qu'un point français
en Grèce en Italie en Allemagne comme je
l'ai déjà évoqué donc la cellule en
tisane je répondrai en même temps
ministre de Brest c'est une cellule
juridique parce que il y a la violence
police gendarmerie casseurs mais il y a
tout le travail qui essaie de faire le
trajet en amont la propriété des
terrains
l'entrisme dans les conseils municipaux
je l'ai dit les contestations sans cesse
des documents d'urbanisme la pression
qui est mis aussi parfois même le
paiement en cash de certains
agriculteurs pour qu'on puisse s'y
installer parfois aussi des menaces
opérer contre certains élus ou contre
certaines autorités et donc il faut
absolument que l'État s'arme alors ça
gendarmerie nous l'avons évoqué mais
quelque part c'est déjà trop tard comme
vous l'avez dit mais ça aussi largement
en amont et j'en profite pour dire que
c'est vraiment un point important il y a
des aides en France il y en a une près
de Dijon par exemple qui pose des
problèmes importants il y a aussi des
occupations illicites où on le sait tous
de terrain depuis plus de 40 ans
notamment en Île-de-France de gens qui
sont installés illégalement parfois à
quelques centaines parfois quelques
milliers de personnes et c'est très
difficile d'évacuer les ânes donc autant
empêcher qu'elle s'installe et donc et
alors moi je sais pas s'il faut changer
la loi monsieur le ministre en tout cas
je pense qu'il faut regarder si le
ministère de l'Intérieur et d'autres
mystères ont tous les moyens pour le
faire ce qui est certain c'est que pour
répondre à votre question aussi sur les
drones les décrets sont désormais au
Conseil d'État après avoir été la CNIL
après un avis favorable dès cet été ne
pourront s'avérer des drôles en
renseignement grâce au travail collectif
que nous avons fait les conseils de
rapporteurs dont vous bien évidemment
sur la PPL Retailleau anti-casseurs moi
je pense qu'il faut remettre sur
l'ouvrage parce que je pense qu'à un
chemin à décision du Conseil
constitutionnel voilà donc je pense
qu'il faudra que le gouvernement
reprenne ses responsabilités ou que vous
les preniez ou que nous les prenions
ensemble et évidemment je voudrais dire
sur les sur les ades nous devons grâce à
cette cellule de juriste faire un état
des lieux et puis en tirer les
conclusions réglementaires législatives
si c'était si c'est des cas mais je veux
dire au ministre Baham a détermination
évidemment à cela mais non ce week-end
là à Sainte-Soline par deux weekends
d'ailleurs de suite les personnes n'ont
pas réussi à installer de ZAD et oui
l'autorité de l'État a été respectée
mais oui cela a été violent et oui il
faut se prévenir contre cela sur je
réponds aussi donc du coup à Monsieur
alamark dont je remercie d'ailleurs de
sa question pour monsieur benaroche je
rentrerai pas dans le débat sur sur
est-ce que les bassines c'est bien ou
c'est pas bien d'ailleurs je pense que
c'est pas le sujet
on peut être contre les bassines et
contre les cocktails Molotov contre les
gendarmes d'ailleurs roche je crois que
votre mouvement politique a fait une
erreur modélique je pense que si la
gauche que vous représentez une partie
de la gauche que vous présentez avait
dit ce qui se passe à sainte-solide est
inacceptable il est évident que les
gendarmes ont été agressés mais que par
ailleurs dans le mouvement social le ce
que vous essayez de faire croire les
ordres étaient donnés pour calmer le
mouvement social je pense que vous
auriez été sans doute plus entendu des
Français mais là vous avez globalisé
peut-être par volonté je dirais pas
Antipolis parce que vous êtes un homme
de bien pas de vos sentiments personnels
je veux plus de d'autres notamment oui
quand on dit que les policiers doivent
se faire rééduquer mentalement comme le
dit Monsieur Longchamp c'est une forme
de terreur et terrorisme intellectuelle
c'est certain oui je dis policiers ça
les aide pas bien se porter et après on
dit pourquoi il y a des suicides chez
les policiers peut-être parce qu'on les
valorise pas tellement leur métier donc
je vous fais pas ce procès monsieur
mélange mais je crois que défendre
sainte Céline comme vous le faites
retire beaucoup à mon avis de de de
points à ceux qui défendent mais
vraiment une cause environnementale dont
il pense que ça ne passe pas par les
bassines et moi je respecte parfaitement
ce point de vue mais je suis un ministre
dans un état de droit et moi j'applique
avec les policiers gendarmes les
décisions de justice il se trouve qu'à
sainte solide c'est pas moi Hassan
solide la justice a validé la
construction de cette bassine on peut
être pour ou contre l'extension d'un
aéroport on peut être pour continuer
d'être GV moi j'ai mon opinion
personnelle pour savoir si vous avez des
bassines ou le tunnel sous la Manche
c'est mon personnel mais il se trouve
que la justice a validé le droit de
propriété et les décisions de justice
sans avoir rester à la loi dit-on c'est
quand même quelque chose que qui touche
à mon avis tous les tous les démocrates
et tous les tous les républicains nous
la doctrine n'a pas été modifiée pour
les manifestations de Paris à partir de
16 mars simplement on a eu pas des
gentils manifestants mais les méchants
d'ultra gauche qui étaient dans ces
manifestations je vous encourage à vous
faire communiquer et là il y a pas
besoin de la négation de renseignement
toutes les instructions données au
préfet et au préfet de police vous
verrez que rien n'a bougé c'était la
même il y a trois mois et la même cette
journée là simplement j'ai essayé de
vous montrer que c'était très différent
alors pour Monsieur Bonhomme il faut
savoir en partie répondu à ces questions
je pense que Monsieur Bonhomme a raison
de dire que bobard est mieux fake news
j'essaierai de me corriger la prochaine
fois gratuit d'avoir la loi tout bon sur
Sylvain c'est Notre-Dame-des-Landes je
reviendrai pas sur les questions
précédentes et je pense que c'est
effectivement une partie de la
complaisance de l'ultra gauche qui nous
touche tous et je pense avoir en partie
répondu à Monsieur à Monsieur bas nous
sommes des land moi je n'ai pas mis de
l'Intérieur à l'époque mais c'est sûr
que lorsque vous faites des opérations
qui relevaient une opération extrêmement
importante de d'évacuation de la ZAD
avec parce que les enseignements à
l'époque là aussi je pense que c'est
intéressant de les consulter des morts
de chaque côté manifestants et policiers
gendarmerie la décision était prise de
ne pas le faire est-ce que c'était bien
de pas le faire c'est votre opinion
politique je la respecte encore faut-il
que il fallait pas laisser installer en
train de landes donc c'est très
difficile d'évacuer des Alpes pour pas
dire c'est extrêmement dangereux et donc
le mieux c'est d'éviter qu'elle
s'installe donc pour l'avenir moi je ne
peux être que d'accord avec vous son
autorité de l'État monsieur Center pour
l'avenir empêchant vous parler de la
Ligue des droits de l'Homme je connais
pas les subventions données par l'État
mais effectivement je pense que ça
mérite ça mérite d'être regardé dans le
cas des actions qu'ils ont pu mener mais
je rappelle que beaucoup de
collectivités locales aussi des finances
voilà non mais je dis représentant des
collectivités locales également que vous
êtes voilà donc ce n'est pas qu'une
question il n'y a pas que l'État enfin
pour Madame benbassade m'en voudrais de
ne pas lui avoir répondu bien évidemment
d'abord ça si vous êtes l'objet de
menaces d'insultes ce dont je doute pas
je les condamne évidemment extrêmement
fortement madame tourdelier a appelé mon
cabinet la semaine dernière elle est
l'objet de menacer d'insulte notamment
ses déplacements elle a été protégée par
les gendarmes de la République à la pub
faire son déplacement il y a des maires
y compris d'ailleurs qui combattent
fortement le gouvernement y compris du
peste que nous protégeons par le SDLP on
en fait pas publicité la police elle est
celle de l'ensemble des Français et
n'est pas bien sûr celle d'un parti
politique et à votre disposition si vous
sentez menacé d'ailleurs n'hésitez pas
on peut faire des évaluations et on peut
faire un accompagnement sans aucun
problème je veux vous dire Madame
sur le groupe uscule et faire de terre
non seulement il a été fermé mais par
ailleurs les services de renseignement
puisque c'est désormais judiciarisé
peuvent connaître l'identité de ces
personnes et seront poursuivies et une
enquête judiciaire
a été ouverte je vous prie de croire
qu'il n'y a pas deux poids de mesure le
trad droite et très dangereuse ultra
gauche est très dangereuse et on devrait
tous être très gêné pour les condamnés
merci Monsieur Miss alors j'ai encore 10
questions il est 12h30 une minute par
personne
donc je regarde bien parce qu'après le
ministre doit répondre et on lèvera à
13h je crois que vous êtes à votre
disposition bon bah 18h donc
allez monsieur bonne Carrère pour une
minute oui monsieur le ministre de
constats très rapide une question
premier constat vous donnez acte du
problème d'ultra gauche et de guérilla
d'une contestation qui seradicalise et
vous redire que nous partageons avec
vous les enjeux d'ordre public deuxième
constat les effets de Domino vous avez
parlé de cellules souches vous avez fait
référence à silence au drame du jeune
Rémi Fraisse il n'y a pas de hasard si
on regarde une situation l'autorité de
l'État n'a pas été respectée au départ
nous avons eu le drame de Sylvain c'est
si vous avez cité maintenant toujours
dans mon département là 69 je pourrais
vous vous démontrer ce que j'appellerais
un arc l'élude et les liens entre les
différents sujets ma question
que personne n'a intérêt à une à la
violence en général est-ce que vous
auriez monsieur le ministre des pistes
pour contribuer à une forme de
désescalade je ne vis pas dans un monde
idéal mais il n'est pas intérêt il n'est
pas interdit de regarder ce qui pourrait
contribuer à une des escalade de la
violence merci de votre attention merci
Monsieur bonne carême Jourda pour une
minute ensuite Monsieur wattulé Merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur ministre
un remerciement d'abord pour le
commissariat de Lorient dont les
policiers ont effectivement été attaqués
avec une violence qu'aucune lutte
sociale ne justifie une observation sur
Notre Dame des Landes je rappelle qu'il
y a eu 179 procès tous gagnés par l'État
Notre-Dame-des-Landes exé sous le
quinquennat de Monsieur Hollande que ces
procès ont tous été purgés et qu'alors
on pouvait agir et enfin une question
vous avez beaucoup évoqué l'ultra gauche
pouvez-vous définir ce qui est l'ultra
gauche
comment on rattache les manifestants à
cet ultra gauche sachant qu'il a été
indiqué que
quand les forces de l'ordre chargent
est-ce qu'il est encore des consignes
qui disent bien voilà ça va se faire en
deux trois temps et on prévient avant ce
qui peut permettre aussi aux gens de se
reculer de pas rester en première ligne
parce qu'on a vu qu'il y a beaucoup de
blessés mais est-ce qu'il y a encore
toujours ses consignes de sécurité en
disant voilà
des sommations est-ce qu'elles sont
encore là voilà puis pour finir je dis
que le dernier mot reste doit rester à
la loi et non pas la loi de quelques-uns
dans la rue merci monsieur madame
l'herbier puis monsieur Lecomte madame
l'herbier bonne minute oui monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre c'était
tout à fait intéressant de vous entendre
ce matin nous rappeler que la démocratie
devait être protégée et vous savez
qu'ici au Sénat c'est une priorité
essentielle il était bon de vous
entendre parler de cette violence
nationale et aussi européenne le schéma
de maintien de l'ordre c'est déjà adapté
plusieurs fois pour être au mieux pour
protéger au plus les citoyens et
je voudrais revenir sur
quelques points je voudrais savoir quels
sont les points essentiels sur lesquels
vous réfléchissez justement en
complément de ce que vient dire mot mon
collègue wadelen pour que ce ne soit pas
une occasion de casse
impuni comment les classeurs
s'organisent comment pouvons-nous nous
parlementaire appuyer législativement
les moyens d'apporter les pour un suivi
judiciaire la preuve des fidélités doit
être suivi de sanctions tout ça c'est
forcément une obligation pour être
entendue l'identification des casseurs
on était sur le même la même idée et
difficile ils sont cagoulés ils sont
dissimulés quelle technique
peuvent être envisagées pour les repérer
pour les les suivre pour les arrêter
sans équivoque nous sommes prêts à
revoir la PPL de Monsieur Retailleau
pourquoi pas c'est essentiel que vous
ayez des moyens d'appui
merci beaucoup madame l'herbier monsieur
Jean-Yves Leconte puis ensuite madame
aribet oui merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre nous sommes tous
d'accord pour dire qu'il y a un problème
d'ordre républicain mais à force de
parler du nom faut pas oublier objective
républicain et je suis assez frappé de
voir en étant assez
attaché à regarder ce qui se passe dans
la basse qui s'écrit dans la presse
européenne et internationale à l'image
durablement atteinte de notre pays
compte tenu de ce qui s'y passe et de ce
qui est observé depuis quelques temps
bien entendu depuis 10 ans les
mobilisations par les réseaux sociaux
rendent le maintien de l'ordre beaucoup
plus compliqué qu'auparavant lorsqu'il
s'agissait tout simplement d'échanger
avec les organisateurs pour cadrer les
choses en amont et les choses se
passaient beaucoup mieux aujourd'hui il
est essentiel d'éviter tout
incompréhension même dans l'opinion
publique pour éviter ceux qui pourraient
profiter des conflits politiques et des
affrontements le respect finalement de
l'ensemble des corps intermédiaires est
indispensable c'est la raison pour
laquelle monsieur le ministre moi je
voudrais vous poser une question très
simple pensez-vous aujourd'hui être en
mesure de faire respecter l'ordre
républicain en étant membre d'un
gouvernement qui depuis 15 jours a quand
même sur ces sujets multiplier les
provocations le mépris et la morgue face
aux incompréhensions et à la volonté
clairement majoritaire de la population
française
merci Monsieur Leconte madame Marie Bay
puis monsieur le kervé
très rapidement parce que vous avez
répondu en partie en répondant madame
bensassin en benne Bassa pardon et en
répondant à Jérôme Durin je voudrais
simplement faire une remarque vous
je suis girondine et dans votre exposé
quand vous expliquez les choses vous ne
parlez que d'ultra gauche alors que vous
êtes tout à fait capable de faire des
réponses équilibrées quand on vous dit
il y a aussi l'ultra droite et sur
Bordeaux vous n'avez pas précisé les
choses il se trouve qu'à Bordeaux a
priori d'après les informations que j'ai
c'était l'extrême droite plus que
l'ultra à moins que ce soit aussi de la
fake news donc je trouve que il est
regrettable que les propos qu'il y ait
besoin de poser la question pour revenir
à l'équilibre des propos et quelque part
ça joue le jeu des ultra-droites et
quand vous parlez des réseaux européens
il me semble que les dangers
actuellement sont plus dans les prises
de pouvoir de l'extrême droite plutôt
que de l'extrême gauche aujourd'hui
voilà c'est simplement je suis
satisfaite par les réponses que vous
avez faites sur cette question
d'équilibre mais je voudrais que elle
puisse cet équilibre puisse être
rencontré sans qu'on ait à poser la
question
merci Madame aribet alors Monsieur Louis
kervé puis monsieur scène Bourgi oui
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre je voulais saisir
la balle au bon et et vous faire part de
disponibilité notre disponibilité
marquée devrait c'est moi sur le sujet
des drones en matière d'ordre public
puisque vous avez répondu à mon collègue
Cora porteur et je pense que c'est un
élément important que nous puissions
regarder encore une fois comment les
choses peuvent évoluer vous avez donné
un certain nombre de perspective
notamment en termes de textes
réglementaire moi le sujet est sur
lequel je vais vous interroger c'est la
question des unités locales de police et
de gendarmerie je me suis rendu auprès
de gendarmes à deux ou trois reprises
ces dernières semaines et au-delà de
sainte Soline la dégradation des
conditions des manifestations est
réelles
Muriel Jourdain vous a parlé de du
département du Morbihan moi je peux voir
vous parler de la Haute-Savoie doit
arriver des manifestants étrangers dans
des manifestations locales qui ne
se comporte absolument pas de la même
manière que
quand les manifestations sont gérées par
les organisations syndicales ça
interpelle ça interroge et je voulais
savoir si vous priez nous donner un
panorama de ce qui peut se passer dans
les dans les départements de la manière
dont vous envisagez peut-être pour
demain d'ailleurs de de gérer ces
questions d'ordre public
merci Monsieur Hervé et Monsieur sainte
Bourgi puis madame merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre je
voudrais commencer par saluer les forces
de l'ordre que je rencontre
régulièrement dans mon département et de
constater les conditions de travail
particulièrement difficile qui sont les
leurs et naturellement ici personne ne
confond
l'écrasante majorité des forces de
l'ordre avec quelques-uns d'entre eux
qui peuvent commettre des actes ou tenir
des propos que nous réprouvons tous et
toutes monsieur le ministre dans l'autre
pays il n'y a pas de police des mots
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure il n'y a
pas de police de la pensée je vous
l'accorde je suis d'accord complètement
d'accord avec vous en revanche dans
notre pays lorsqu'on est un responsable
politique nous le sommes tous et toutes
ici nous devons cultiver la nuance nous
le don nous devons nous efforcer de
rechercher la vérité et de la dire
parce que mal nommé les choses c'est
rajouter au malheur du monde comme le
disait Albert Camus dans votre exposé
luminaire vous avez répété au moins 40
fois le mot ultra gauche dans les
réponses que vous avez faites aux
questions de mes collègues vous avez
répété une quinzaine de fois le mot
ultra gauche je voulais juste vous dire
quand
lisant les articles de presse en
échangeant avec les représentants des
forces de l'ordre avec les organisations
syndicales le tableau est beaucoup plus
mitigé beaucoup plus nuancé parce
qu'effectivement il y a des personnes
qui relèvent de ce que vous appelez la
mouvance ultra gauche il y a des
personnes qui ne se revendiquent ni de
gauche ni de droite qui se disent
libertaire ou anarchiste mais il y a
aussi monsieur le ministre et vous le
savez et je regrette que vous n'ayez pas
précisé des casseurs qui viennent juste
pour chaparder et pour voler c'est le
cas dans les grandes villes c'est pas le
gars à Sainte-Souline mais à l'occasion
des manifestations ou en marge des
manifestations qui se tiennent dans les
grands centres urbains de nos pays il y
a des gens qui ne sont ni de gauche ni
de droite mais qui viennent profiter
pour casser pour chaparder pour voler
c'est la raison pour laquelle je tenais
vraiment à insister sur ce point-là
parce qu'effectivement si on veut être
audible et crédible aux yeux de
l'opinion publique et des personnes qui
subissent ces dégradations nous devons
utiliser les bons mots monsieur le
ministre je voulais vous interroger très
précisément sur un point qui est celui
des interdictions administratives des
territoires vous les avez évoqué depuis
quelques années il y a des flux de
casseurs qui viennent de l'étranger dans
notre pays est-ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
pouvez nous dire précisément le nombre
de personnes qui ont fait l'objet d'une
ID et de quel pays venait-il merci merci
Monsieur Bourgi madame Marie Mercier je
me suis Henri Leroy merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre
tout le monde ici condamne la violence
elle était terrifiante elle est
terrifiante d'où qu'elle vienne moi je
voudrais insister sur le climat de
violence qui règne dans notre société je
pense qu'il y a une cause même plusieurs
qui sont très profonds puisqu'elles
commencent même à la maternelle qu'elle
est violence intrafamiliale qui explose
donc nous vivons dans un climat violent
la manifestation elle était interdite
pouvez-vous me dire si c'est pour ça
qu'il n'y avait peut-être pas la Croix
Rouge ou d'autres d'autres véhicules de
secours si ils étaient là pourquoi ils
n'ont pas pu intervenir et quand il y a
eu ses blessés je n'ai pas très bien
compris pourquoi les véhicules n'ont pas
pu accéder sur les lieux plus vite vous
avez dit que des blessés empêchaient
peut-être son arrivée est-ce qu'elle est
seulement les blessés qui s'accrochait à
ce véhicule du Samu le médecin du GIGN
est intervenu semble que lui était plus
près il lui a fallu quand même plus
d'une heure pour secourir on savait que
probablement ça allait être violent vous
avez dit qu'il y avait 42 projets qui
risquaient d'entraîner des déchaînements
comme ça donc est-ce que ça peut pas
être anticipé de façon à ce que les
secours au moins arrivent arrivent plus
vite
merci Madame merci et puis Monsieur
Henri Leroy monsieur le Président merci
merci aussi monsieur le ministre pour
toutes les précisions que vous nous avez
apportées lors de votre intervention
illustrée par des aides pédagogiques
percutantes et significative l'extrême
violence est en ascension vertigineuse
dans la grande majorité des pays
européens
l'ensemble des mesures d'ordre technique
juridique et administrative ne suffisent
plus à faire face efficacement à ce
déchaînement d'exaction de violence et
de haine les groupuscules d'extrême
droite ou gauche c'est la même chose
vous les avez vous avez constaté
vous-même d'ailleurs par votre présence
sur le terrain monsieur le ministre à
Caen des mesures adéquates pour
maîtriser ces situations qui ne feront
que s'aggraver tant qu'un train de
disposition plus coercitive à la hauteur
des à la hauteur de de ces menaces ne
seront pas prises les forces de l'ordre
les attentes et vous le savez puisque
vous avez été à leur contact très
souvent dernièrement merci merci
Monsieur Laura si vous me permettez une
question
je m'autorise une question
mais une minute alors une minute
monsieur godet surveille les
protestations qui sont venues de des
commissaires du Conseil de l'Europe ou
de l'ONU sont souvent connus par voie de
presse moi j'aimerais savoir si vous
avez vos services ont des contacts
directs avec ces différentes
organisations parce qu'il y a quelques
semaines la commission des lois s'est
transportée soit la CEDH soit au Conseil
de l'Europe et nous avons eu des
échanges
très intéressants et qui démontre que on
doit avoir ce dialogue en tous les cas
qu'il était plus intense mais face à des
déclarations de cette nature comment
cela est-il géré à votre niveau en tous
les cas entre le ministère et ses
organisations si toutefois cela existe
merci est-ce que je fais une minute 30
secondes
celui que j'avais la parole puis après
nous les vend la séance merci monsieur
le Président pour répondre directement à
votre question je les ai découvert
également par votre presse
d'ailleurs effectivement nous avons fait
savoir parce que vous savez que en tout
cas pour ce qui est du Conseil de
l'Europe à l'ambassadeur qui est là que
ce serait bien qu'effectivement et on
comprend très bien les remarques que ça
peut être qui peut être fait que ce
serait bien que nous puissions également
l'avoir de façon peut-être officielle
peut-être même quelques minutes avant ce
serait même une autre chose ne serait-ce
que pour avec un contradictoire puisse
exister voilà j'espère que nous
améliorons évidemment
ces discussions et en général encouragé
que ce soit le commissaire évoqué ou le
Conseil de l'Europe à venir là aussi
rencontrer les forces de l'ordre puisque
à ma connaissance peut-être que mes
services me disent pas tout mais je
pense que si on avait représentant de
l'ONU ou le Conseil d'Europe quelque
part on me le dirait qu'il puisse venir
voir quel service rencontrer les
policiers des gendarmes directement les
interroger et bien sûr faire ce travail
contradictoire bien évidemment
peut-être dire puisque ça a été évoqué
d'abord moi je qualifie pas l'ultra
gauche ou l'ultra droite comme faisant
partie de la droite et de la gauche et
moi ce qui m'étonne d'ailleurs dans dans
le retour notamment sur
l'ultra gauche et que vous regardez dire
c'est une discussion de la gauche c'est
pas la gauche c'est une dragoche ultra
droite ce sont des mouvements qui sont
qualifiés comme ça depuis très longtemps
d'ailleurs je l'ai rappelé il y a pas si
longtemps que ça et c'est pas pour vos
questions c'est par vérité historique
que ce qu'on puisse combattre le dragon
c'est la gauche quand elle était en
responsabilité et dire une très grande
partie des personnes qui sont affichées
au service de renseignement l'ont été
comme Manuel Valls et Bernard cazas
étaient mises à l'intérieur donc moi je
ne confonds pas bien évidemment le
travaux chez la gauche d'ailleurs je
m'étonne Kodi et pourquoi pas et
pourquoi vous dit pas assez ultra-droite
il se trouve que là
c'est l'ultra gauche je peux pas dire
autre chose Monsieur le Sénateur d'air
je dis à Madame la créatrice non en tout
cas à ma connaissance une enquête qui
est ouverte mais à ma connaissance
aucune information n'est remontée pour
dire que c'était l'ultra droite qui
était responsable de ce qui s'est passé
à Bordeaux et d'ailleurs je que un
député de la France insoumise en
l'occurrence monsieur Coquerel me
semble-t-il sur une chaîne de grande
écoute et désignée
un mouvement politique sans avoir aucune
espèce de preuve voilà si c'est à la fin
du travail je le dirai bien volontiers
je les combats de la même manière à
Bordeaux j'ai dit sous l'association
Bordeaux nationaliste c'était en
décembre 2022 il y a pas si longtemps
que ça et même monsieur Mélenchon le
premier février dernier m'a félicité par
la suite qui restait archivé aux
Archives nationales tellement il est
incroyable
pour dire que j'avais pour dire que
salut mon action je suis mise à part qui
a dissout génération identitaire
tout le monde a parlé y compris des
gouvernements précédents ça n'a pas été
fait dans des conditions très très
difficiles et valider d'ailleurs par le
Conseil d'État donc
il se trouve madame la sénatrice que
l'on m'interroge là sur ce qui s'est
passé je ne peux pas vous dire autre
chose que la vérité des faits qu'à notre
connaissance et des services de
renseignement c'est ultra gauche
maintenant si le président veut
m'inviter pour que je parle de la menace
accélérationniste ou suprémaciste je le
fais bien volontiers mais ce n'est pas
l'objet de l'actualité d'aujourd'hui
voilà donc n'y voyez pas quelque chose
une sorte de poursuite au théâtre pour
parler d'autre chose c'est la vérité que
je constate personnellement que je crois
beaucoup de chargeur constate l'ultra
gauche vous me demandez une définition
on me dit même que la mairie de Bordeaux
5 individus ont été interpellée passé au
garde-à-vis un écrou et deux contrôle
judiciaire et jusqu'à présent à notre
connaissance mais surtout des magistrats
qui ont pu communiquer aucun lien avec
l'extrême droite refermé ça veut pas
dire que n'aura pas de ma voix après
demain c'est à dire que personne ne peut
le dire aujourd'hui moment où nous
parlons voilà
ultra-droite est déjà assez dangereux
comme ça pour que on lui passe par
ailleurs des des choses qu'elle aurait
manifestement pas faite encore une fois
je mets du conditionnel parce que
l'enquête te dira pour moi l'ultra
gauche fait pour les services de
renseignement aussi c'est un mouvement
ou des militants qui légitime le recours
à l'action en violente parce qu'il
refuse les règles institutionnelles
voilà évidemment
il y a plus de volonté culturelles
anarchique même si je ne confonds pas
les anarchistes avec le dragon parce que
j'ai dit mais voyez ce que je ce que je
veux dire il y a moins de volonté
d'organisation et c'est plus nébuleux
c'est plus difficile il y a c'est vrai
une Internationale ultra droite mais par
nature et nationalistes alors que
l'ultra gauche par nature et plus
internationaliste d'ailleurs le fait que
l'arrivée dans des causes que ce soit en
France ou ailleurs j'ai parlé des
manifestations du G7 ou du G20 à en
Angleterre ou ou en Allemagne montrent
que nous constatons qu'il y a beaucoup
plus
d'échanges internationaux c'est-à-dire
qu'il n'a pas le traite ça veut dire que
ce n'est pas la même nature donc c'est
pas les mêmes mouvements c'est pas un
parallèle de miroir où on dirait ben
voilà on a deux structures qu'il
faudrait combattre c'est pas les mêmes
modes d'action il y a d'ailleurs une
paranoïa avancée très forte en Ultra
gauche qui utilise des crypto qui
utilisent des messageries cryptées que
n'utilise pas toujours
ultra-droite un peu mais pas toujours
c'est pas la même culture il y a une
culture du clandestin
ultra gauche que les pâtes toujours
celui de l'ultra droite qui va jusqu'à
porter des insignes donc voilà
évidemment il y a beaucoup de plus de
subtilités dans la réalité de ce que je
j'évoque mais ça pour vous montrer les
différences auxquelles à la difficulté
des services de renseignement sur
monsieur wabled bon et je répondrai en
même temps Madame l'herbier qui passe
finalement la même question
alors la reconnaissance faciale je suis
pas tout à fait certain que ça nous
aiderait mais en tout cas je me suis
déjà exprimé sur ce point ce qui est
certain c'est que dans l'identité des
personnes
il y a
un travail très fort que mettre en place
de contournement les extrémistes
violents pour éviter d'être identifiés
et d'ailleurs une partie de ces
personnes pas tous d'une partie font
partie des classes bourgeoises pour
parler voilà j'ai moi-même dit j'ai
essayé de démontrer par un jeu de mots
je sais que ce bon degré n'est pas dans
les rendez-vous politique et avait été
dit mais il y a un petit côté black
Bourges tous les services de
renseignement les politiques vont
rencontrer vous dit mais vous savez
c'est pas des gens des quartiers ou des
cités qui font ça c'est pas les ouvriers
en colère qui font ça c'est beaucoup
d'enfants de bonne famille Kaby dans des
bosses arrondissements parisiens qui ont
des professions ou qui sont sur des
études extrêmement importantes et qui
trouvent un intérêt à la violence est-ce
que c'est un intérêt passager ou est-ce
que ça intéresse continue
l'avenir nous le dira mais enfin c'est
pas très nouveau ceux qui font la
révolution dans la rue contestataire
c'est rarement les fils ouvriers ça peut
arriver mais enfin chacun se rappelle
des exemples d'histoire et donc par
nature ils sont plusieurs organisés ils
ont compris le principe général de
l'action de la police et de la
gendarmerie et l'action de la justice
d'ailleurs vous savez moi je suis allé
voir les CRS à Lambersart parce que
Lille avait été très touché par les
manifestations ils m'ont donné les
documents que qu'ils ont trouvé sur les
personnes et de ce document tout aussi
bien fait que ce que je vous ai montré
il y avait non seulement comment
s'équiper mais quel cabinet d'avocats
appelé parce qu'il faut appeler lui
plutôt que tel autre qu'est-ce qu'il
faut dire au service de police dans la
garde à vue quelqu'un qui est violent
parce que il est touché dans son usine
dans sa famille ça peut arriver c'est
évidemment inexcusable mais ça peut
arriver il n'est pas dans l'organisation
de la violence il est dans la
spontanéité de la violence des dockers
qui sont en colère ça peut être très
violent évidemment mais ils ont pas
organisé la violence et la revendique
même de faire que la violence est un
mode d'action pour faire entendre leurs
causes là il y a une part de
dissémination et d'organisation qui
devrait nous inquiéter il y a une
organisation derrière tout ça alors
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire vous savez
moi je pense que principal dans le
trafic de drogue d'ailleurs on pourrait
en parler comme dans ces manifestations
c'est que nous continuons avec le même
travail de renseignement qui est
c'est-à-dire les écoutes téléphoniques
classiques mais écoutez les classiques
donnent de moins en moins de choses
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs vous
utilisez nous utilisons télégram signal
WhatsApp c'est-à-dire pas les lignes
téléphoniques classiques si les gens
honnêtes comme vous le font les jambes
malhonnêtes le font par définition
puisque ils savent que c'est par là
qu'ils ne sont pas entendus et donc ce
que vous nous avez autorisé en
terrorisme c'est à dire la captation à
distance et la possibilité d'aller
utiliser la technologie pour prendre en
main votre téléphone toujours sur le
contrôle de la Commission nationale des
techniques de renseignement est toujours
sous le contrôle de la justice vous
devriez pardon mais nous l'autoriser
dans la lutte contre les trafiquants de
stups qui ont beaucoup plus
organisations que le terrorisme parfois
ou dans les actions extrêmement
violentes je vous dis que de la terreur
pourrait s'installer pour surveiller
l'ultra droite pour sauver l'ultra
gauche il faut je vais pas rentrer dans
le détail mais pour connaître le groupe
télégram évoqué tout à l'heure pendant
ça il faut un travail humain c'est pas
un travail technique puisque nous ne
pouvons pas rentrer sur télégramme ou
nous l'autorisez pas donc si vous voulez
tenez les moyens à l'état de ce protéger
mais ça pose des tas de questions de
liberté publique de liberté individuelle
d'échange d'informations qui sont bien
plus complexes que les quelques instants
que j'évoquais vous donnez-nous en
terrorisme ce que donnez-nous pour le le
trafic de Sup de grande ampleur pour la
criminalité organisée et pour la
violence des extrêmes les mêmes
techniques de renseignement que vous
avez pour le terrorisme le terrorisme je
dis pas que demain soir ou ce soir ou
demain matin il y aura pas un attentat
il y en a quand même eu 41 des jouets
depuis 2017 et je vous signale qu'en
corrière le service de renseignement
alors là ça fait pas de bruit tant mieux
vont interpeller y compris
un adolescent de 14 ans qui se retrouve
avec des choses extrêmement dangereuses
chez lui et dont on pense on peut penser
il y a une enquête que par le plâtre que
ça aurait pu donner quelque chose de
très grave et c'était encore le cas il y
a trois mois et c'est quasiment le cas
tous les trimestres vous nous avez donné
les moyens de lutter contre ça la loi
aujourd'hui ne donne pas forcément les
moyens de répondre à cette nouvelle
menace en tout cas continuez de faire
les écouter téléphoniques à la papa au
moment où tout le monde utilise des
messages décryptés c'est peut-être
donner mettre une main dans le dos au
policier gendarmes pour lutter pour
d'autres sécurité voilà j'ai déjà dire
attention à la commission la commission
des lois
je crois que j'ai répondu donc pour
Bordeaux pour Monsieur Hervé je pense en
partie avoir répondu à cela mais je veux
dire qu'il a raison de dire que la
nature des manifestations changent alors
c'est vrai c'est pas vrai parce que sur
ça on manifestation il y en a 98 qui se
passera très très bien j'ai l'habitude
de dire le préfet de police tous les
vendredis il vient me voir et il me
montre une carte de Paris et vous
verriez ce que vous serez mis à
l'intérieur Monsieur Hervé vous aurez 30
manifestations à gérer tous les
week-ends les opposants à tel le
gouvernement si les sans-papiers là les
professeurs en colère les médecins pas
contents les parlementaires chirales les
manifestations et parfois des raisons
très importantes
et c'est le cas partout en France la
difficulté c'est que dans certaines
manifestations quand vous l'avez dit il
y a non seulement le train gauche et de
la violence mais par ailleurs il y a à
la fois c'est ce qu'a dit je crois tout
à l'heure monsieur monsieur Bourget il y
a pas les mêmes services d'ordre qu'il y
a 30 ans
c'est un fait et il y a des personnes
étrangères qui sont les professionnels
de la contestation et donc oui nous
réfléchissons avec les prises
européennes à essayer de comprendre ce
phénomène qui est un phénomène
inquiétant que nous pensons qui est
organisé et que j'essaie d'évoquer pour
Monsieur Bourgy je voudrais rappeler
qu'il y a donc
488iat actuellement en vigueur bon il
n'est pas là mais je suis sûr qu'ils
nous entendra et par ailleurs il y en a
eu une dizaine pour sainte Soline
c'est-à-dire il y a-t-elle est toujours
notifié c'est-à-dire qu'on a pu voir les
personnes c'est pas comme une arrêtée
quelconque qui n'est pas qui n'est pas
valable il y a T c'est donc
l'interdiction d'entrer sur le
territoire national beaucoup du trac à
gauche ont du stabiliste ou très droite
ont des iat et donc par définition sont
bloquées sans qu'on en prenne puisque
c'est je veux dire elle est plutôt prise
auparavant la question de monsieur
bonnekare est une question importante il
a raison et j'ai cité muret j'espère de
pas être pédant en cité en René Girard
qui pense effectivement que violence est
mimétique et que c'est sûr que quand on
va pas vers des escalades le bouquet
bisser arrive alors c'est les policiers
c'est c'est qui on veut et que il veut
essayer de faire descendre cette
violence pimétique comme dans tout il
explique ainsi la vie du christianisme
mais on pourrait expliquer évidemment
dans plein d'autres choses oui on y
réfléchit voilà pour cette audition de
Gérald de Darmanin que vous suivez sur
notre antenne depuis 11h15 on retiendra
cet avertissement du ministre de
l'Intérieur s'insoline ce n'est que le
début elle dit Gérald Darmanin 42
projets sont enregistrés par les
services de renseignement comme étant
comme étant ceux qui peuvent faire
naître des contestations extrêmement
violentes voilà donc pour cette audition
vous avez pu suivre sur notre antenne
prochain rendez-vous à 13h avec Oriane
Mancini bonjour chez vous je vous
retrouve et bien dans l'émission des 14
heures consacrée aux questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement et présenté
par Tam tra